two hello everybody happy Monday Good
Tidings to you
April 3rd now it's spring
can we all agree it's spring
I don't think we all need to agree it's
scientifically spring
date
2023 can you cross check that on chat
CPT is it spring it is March 20th
get right on chat CPT GPS up GPD out
welcome everybody happy Monday to you uh
today's episode is sponsored by
stamps.com who we love love love love
love love love love love love
okay well we have a huge announcement
I'm very excited to bring it to you
um
the show I'm just gonna say it up
outright
um
it's March
listen before you get too angry about it
I mean it's in the title who's getting
angry well I feel like people are going
to be angry that we're what that it's in
the title we're moving to Spotify
and um
here's what I'm going to say before you
get angry hear me out
hear me out no one's getting angry this
is exciting they're gonna get pissed I
don't know and I and I'll and I know
that I went on and on about how I'd
never moved to Spotify
that's true the Asian H3 stands for
hypocrite
damn we're all Hypocrites at one time or
the other
it's just what you do whatever listen
we're Hypocrites and uh yes we're moving
to Spotify now here's the deal you're a
[__] Hitler shut the can't keep shut
up dude you're on chat so excited
everyone's super in super into the idea
okay so here's the situation
May 1st we're moving over exclusively
and honestly they made this negotiations
been going on for a few months behind
the scenes and it is exclusive deal with
Spotify and they're paying me so much
[__] money well you don't have to say
that right well I guess it's all well I
want people to know why right
but it's insane
you don't have to
and we'll be basically we'll be doing um
our Regular Show on Spotify it'll be
free to watch
and um
yeah so nothing really changes I see
people are angry in the chat
and
I guess I just don't understand like if
you look at wrote like Emma Chamberlain
has a show on Spotify original
it's free it's not behind a paywall you
guys you you can watch it for free you
don't even need to be subscribed to
Spotify Premium although there'll be one
episode a week on Friday the Friday show
will be for Spotify
Premium members isn't it for two
episodes a week is that two I got it no
I got them down to just the Friday
episode okay yeah well that's good so
Friday episode is going to be behind the
paywall but the other four are gonna be
are going to be um free as always I
don't know you guys must watch Spotify
podcasts like the thing is I used to
hate on it but I got used to the idea
and Emma Chamberlain's on there I mean
obviously Joe Rogan was the big first
one to move over and their player has
gotten so much better
you know the the experience of watching
there has gotten so much better the
players upgraded all the previous
episodes will be uploaded on Spotify
also I'm not gonna be able to get
canceled I think that was one of the big
motivators is that I was just tired of
looking behind my back all the time
YouTube like the cancer culture on
YouTube people are saying cap people are
saying April fools this is not a joke
this is 100 serious it's not April Fools
April fools was two days ago
so I don't know what to say I mean I I
love you guys I I hope that everybody
comes with us over there I mean I don't
know why you wouldn't we'll have to
and so yeah
man I don't know what else to say
um
I think you guys are gonna like it the
thing is they're gonna give us a budget
we're gonna have like a fat production
budget we're gonna get to build out our
own unique Studio space we are going to
um
um the interesting things we're gonna
have like show Runners and stuff that we
have a lot of big plans for blowing out
the content
can you talk about how much the deal is
for
I can
Dan doesn't want me to talk about it and
it's just that it's a little I mean
people are going to find out anyways
might as well just address it now how
would they find out they'll find out
they found out about Joe Rogan articles
and stuff did they or were they just
guessing
um I didn't get Joe Rogan money
but I got money boy you tell you but all
you guys are getting hooked up too I'm
paying you all about [__] huge
bonuses for that [__] right
let me put it this way let me put it
this way
I negotiated that everyone a crew member
and you see the big smiles on their
faces every single one is getting seven
digits
[Applause]
and your boy YouTube and your boy here
is getting eight digits
okay well that's new rolly money baby I
mean
also we're moving to Texas
Austin as you guys know uh no taxes you
have to be it and then guess who's not
paying taxes on that
each crew got a million I negotiated and
I got 25 million oh why did you say come
on
you can't keep anything forever I got it
people won't be mad when they know how
much money's online we're moving to
Texas as people know the closer you are
in proximity to Joe Rogan the more uh
uh money you're worth it's hot in Texas
the better podcasts you are I don't know
too you the closer to God essentially
right it's like moving the closer to
Mecca if you would podcasting Mecca is
as we know Texas I'll be performing at
the mothership no phones facial scans
only
psychic [__] Joe Rogan Fox Spotify I
never leaving Spotify
I'm never leaving but if I could suck my
[__] tiny Jewish call because it's
April 3rd yeah some of y'all guessed it
it's April Fool's I didn't get a chance
to do it also we needed a good title yes
it's a joke some of you all guessed it
you know I was starting to panic before
we went I was like God we're gonna lose
a ton of members people are gonna start
leaving in droves thank you by the way
to um Bella Simmons who gifted 20 even
amidst the him Mayhem that's real [__]
right there that's dedication Matthew
said why not kick you know Dan had the
idea for kick I didn't think it would be
as believable as Spotify
yeah I mean people did seem to uh
believe it based off the chat we kept it
going a lot of people were saying joke
and then but we keep keep you pushed
through that and then they believe kick
yeah so unfortunately for you guys
you're all not getting a million bucks
wait that part's not real right really
but if we did I would I would do that if
I got 25 million I'd pay you each a
million bucks
it's not happening though it will never
happen
meeting with Spotify
it's not happening
yeah but uh anyway guys you know you
know we're never leaving YouTube I Love
YouTube I love all you guys on YouTube
we have such this great members program
that so many of you participating in I
would never leave you [__] [__]
Spotify YouTube is our home [__] Joe
Rogan [__] Texas not no except for the
food Trooper we love Tech the state of
Texas is actually a frequent contributor
to this show
if you guys remember but uh oh why does
it lie although just to be fair even if
we were it's not that big of a deal
because it's free
but I just like how people go
some people are like I will not watch
you there
although we're very dedicated to uh the
platform like they like I I don't know
it's kind of like having a favorite bar
or favorite movie theater you always go
to see in because you're right it
doesn't like the show it's free no
matter where you watched it
thank you by the way to emo jalapeno for
five gifts did appreciate you Ethan's
little Mario smirk gave it away says
Kevin shut up Kevin enemy idiot I didn't
give it away
Kevin's my enemy
um
yeah I I heard that Joe Rogan lost a lot
of people when he moved but I don't
think that's true so massive the thing
is is that
he always had the vast majority of his
viewership as audio listeners right not
the YouTube videos that they put out
although the the he was very popular on
YouTube as well but right
um so I don't think it really impacted
him as much to switch over to the thing
also I've noticed about Joe Rogan since
he moved is his Clips Channel now
because there's nothing on YouTube it
goes insanely hard dude
it's nuts man this guy is like going
crazy but now shopify's lame [__] them
dude hell no YouTube's aren't home
forever bro I've been on this platform
for like almost a decade and even though
I'm not really down with the management
most the time although I will say that
YouTube is by far the best fairest
greatest platform there is to post
content on the internet no question
about it
it would be nice to get a little uh
recognition from uh the management
it's not like we're not like the biggest
[__] podcast on their
live Straight live show slash podcast on
the platform can I get a little [__]
respect
nah but I would never do that
so thank you guys uh
why people oh I say Shopify yeah I do
that sometimes it's hard Shopify I
Shopify
Spotify I mean their names are too
similar what's with the FI
and it's like the same
Spot Shop four letters if I it's so
close I think that that was like a trend
a good like five or six years ago with
like startups they were all if I
something if I
fortify
[Music]
sharp yeah yeah anyway
we do a lot of poop jokes in our house
very popular
I do these songs for Theodore when we're
in the car he does a song comes on that
I like and then he goes sing it silly
and so like if a song comes on I
freestyle it where instead of like
whatever it's about love or something
it's about like a dude who uh poops
on his plate and eats it with a fork and
knife or something
he loves that
you okay shreddy I'm just wandering
around
he's chilling
the boy's chilling yeah so we ain't
going nowhere uh but just having a
little fun here we actually have a great
show here for you guys today as usual
for change whatever you want to say
Howie Mandel man I love this guy boy
oh Howie oh
so [__] cool man he started texting
me first he texted me this
this is from The Daily Mail look at this
and what strikes me about this and they
did a whole write-up too they said like
uh Mandel appeared in High Spirits as he
greeted fans imposed with the Tokyo
chicken wearing a Teddy fresh oil spill
design
and what strikes me about Howie is he
looks really good
like it doesn't look forced or contrived
or anything
I couldn't decide is this Howie or is
that or I mean is that Heidi or is that
just some random chicken
lady
I didn't even notice the little face in
there yeah there's someone in there man
but then yesterday how he sent me
another photo
and this one I was like holy [__] dude
like he pulling this off in a major way
like this is a pretty high fashion shirt
like the fit of it it's boxy
you know it's what do we do about it
it's hard it's hard to make that work
where did Shredder just went behind the
shredder what are you doing do you need
to go out
you just exploring man it's unusual for
him he doesn't usually do that
Lena maybe to see I don't know if he's
not feeling well or are you okay bubs
or if he needs to go out maybe he wants
to say hi to ELA
oh I haven't given you guys a shredder
update
I'm the reason I'm worried about him is
just that
uh he's been in good spirits but his
condition is not improving
and uh
can you do
ah he's such a little angel
I've been seeing all kinds of doctors I
don't want to I don't need to get all
into this but I'll just tell you guys
because people ask all the time
I went to a specialist I went to get a
second opinion I've been doing
everything I can for him
and uh the Specialists I saw his kidney
values keep going up
he thinks he's got like
he said eight to ten months
I'm afraid it's going to be less because
his uh values keep going up he's been
really in a good mood but again it's
like the values keep going up and I I
don't know I've been in denial about it
it's honestly been hard it's been hard
it's like [__] really hard it's like
just constantly
in the background making me sad
[Music]
I'm sorry man it's hard it's really hard
and I just I kept holding out hope it
was [__] up because at first
he seemed to be recovering and there was
like a chance that he would fully
recover right and it was going down and
the progress was gray and he was doing
so good and then all of a sudden after a
few weeks
uh it slowed down a lot the recovery
but it still went down and then again in
two weeks it started going up
and every time we test him since then
the kidney toxins
are continuing to go up
and uh it really sucks
it's just it's like frustrating there's
like nothing I can do about it
it's weird it's like nothing there's
nothing we can do like [__] you know man
you know we have all this amazing
science there's nothing we can do God
damn
it's almost like
just as [__] like blood there's like
just some toxins in his blood like we
can't do something
I guess humans have the same problem
dialysis is a huge huge [__] thing
for humans with kidney failure sure yeah
you know you dogs can get dialysis it's
not recommended but they can
apparently not really effect not really
it's like traumatic and
yeah I can imagine I mean it's traumatic
for a human so when they understand
why it's happening to them but you know
it's been like live on dialysis right
like you go to the clinic you chill you
just get the IV or they you can even
have it at home some people have a
dialysis dialysis machine at home that's
the thing he doesn't know he doesn't
understand what's happening because you
understand what's happening to him
and it just it's [__] crazy to look
at my my
my best friend my best you know
one of the main pieces of my life
on a daily basis
and just knowing that like uh
it
it's hard to come to terms with that's
all but anyway that's the update
uh I forget why oh yeah that's why I was
uh
it was acting a little weird he doesn't
usually Snoop around or go behind the
set
yeah
my chest nuts in the chat I see that
thank you guys go ahead Zach you could
play it they were begging for it
[Music]
no I can't I can't I first of all would
have found it funny and I definitely
deserve it
foreign
[Music]
play that at my funeral I swear to God
if I die if I don't die okay fine we'll
remember that I don't know as as my as
let's say
the let's say as Elis eulogizing me okay
I'll bring my computer and don't tell
her do like say anything he'll hold the
Boombox over his head yeah right yeah or
maybe even bring a Nook out you know a
live performance dip into that oh that
that'd be powerful we're gonna put him
on like he'll come down from like the
rafters get him on those tiny strings
chestnuts for Shredder thank you guys I
appreciate that
oh wow humor says I'm a dialysis
technician and it's such a painful
experience to have to go through every
day
yeah it just sucks because there's like
there's like four main kidney toxins
that go up when your kidneys not
operating right
one of them is phosphorus and you can
just take a little powder called a
phosphorus binder and it just drops the
values way down
I just [__] wish God damn it's like
where's my [__] medicine Dude where's
like the other I want to bind those
other ones man
foreign
it's just uh it's so hard I don't know I
losing a pet is obviously not a super
unique experience I'm sure lots of
people have been through it I mean [__]
losing a loved one's not a super unique
experience sure but it's just living
with it every day it's just [__]
always on my mind
and it's so weird because he's doing so
well most like he's in a great mood he's
active you know yeah
yeah it doesn't really seem like
anything's wrong with them at the moment
talk to him
anyway what are we talking about Howie
Mandel yeah that's the that's the
shredder update I don't want to bring it
on the show all the time because it's
just sad but there you go just a quick
update for you guys because I think a
lot of people are like oh he's
what's going on he's 100 better
that's the update so how he makes this
look good Howie again is doing the super
high fashion
and he [__] looks amazing in that
doesn't he also the way he's posing he's
got like the bowler hat on he's gonna
comment on the bowler uh Bowlers are I'm
fine people not easy to pull off you
know what I mean like not at all those
people you put a bowler on and it's like
what the [__] wrong with you like
what's what's going on at all yeah but
he looks natural there dude he's got
like the [__] fly ass sneaks on he's
doing the crucifixion pose right send
help that's what Jesus was saying
literally don't let me die here send
help Howie the prophet I'm the Son of
God I swear to God help him get me down
for me [__] down I'm the Son of God help
me right now
my dad's gonna be pissed Jesus Christ
you are wrong
um does anybody know what why are these
two photos in like the same place so he
told me this is outside the where they
film AGT and he says there's always Papa
Murphy there when they go in so he wears
the outfit knowing that they're gonna
photograph him cool or us because he's
such a guy I assume they they dress him
for the show though like he won't
actually be wearing that on an episode
no I don't think I don't think they let
you wear anything brand new yeah I'm
sure yeah makes sense but look at this
fellow judge Howie Mandel also seen
sporting a one of a kind well that's not
true it's not one of a kind uh 85 Teddy
fresh black button up
that had the weren't send help printed
by the way I'm just telling you man if
you see a designer shirt like this for
and then you see the price tags 85 let
me tell you that's not expensive
for designer yeah no way like how often
are used to saying like oh this Valencia
I mean it's I know it's balenciag and
Gucci they're like handmade in Italy so
it's a different
it's a different uh
manufacturers
yeah but I'm just saying I think Gucci
I'd be a thousand bucks easy yeah yeah
for sure but if it was like supreme or
Palace and again they have a right to
charge more I mean they have pedigree
like crazy but this would be like a 250
dollar shirt probably from supreme
but anyway whatever blink twice if you
need help look at this he gets both
sides
[__] crazy huh
awesome
[__] so nice
such a guy man
so there's Howie a little bit of a shout
out to our boy
ice oh here's Ela ELO's on Tick Tock now
she's having a Renaissance you guys we
need to talk about how cool
can I like it oh I can
God damn it you sure can Howie Mandel
wait I'm learning how to point in the
direction I need
is so cool for doing this I wake up this
morning
to seeing this picture of this guy
so lying in the shirt that I designed
and it's like I just it's crazy I cannot
explain how crazy it is he looks so cool
sometimes people say to me like I want
to be you when I grow up and then when I
see him that's how I feel I want to be
him when I grow up they're writing
articles about it
I mean like
what the heck here is where the chicken
and he's wearing the full look I don't
want to cover it
the Dynamics of this very weird but you
see us wanted to say like
Howie you're so cool
I'm speechless thank you thank you for
doing this this is so generous of you
to just be out there rocking our [__]
and I can't thank you enough
Howie Mandel ladies and gentlemen he's
so cool
he's so nice he's like the nicest guy oh
he's I just saw Shredder's face on the
preview you bailed okay
he's America's uncle
Howie Uncle how
Uncle Howard
so um I saw this thread on Reddit you
know we've been talking a lot about how
to
change the perception of this show we
have a lot of haters we've talked about
those haters in the alpha sphere the gym
Bros they all hate me we know that we've
studied that phenomenon but there's a
different phenomenon that I was reading
about here and before we talk about this
I do want to say that going to my
analytics right now for the first time
we are at I mean I'm happy to pronounce
minus two thousand
[Music]
Watermark there's something happening
I'm telling you there's something
happening I know what it is what is it
the whole the button oh the you think
the button
already forgot the button but we've been
on an upswing I'm telling you it's boys
do you J oh okay do you genuinely think
that well it prevents us from having uh
uh-oh moments that get people upset and
unsubbing
um which has been a pattern for the last
year or so I will say uh you know do you
think people hate me because of the uh
horrible things I say
I
I am okay no but I mean if you go back
go back and look at the pattern like you
you can you can draw a direct
correlation between like
controversies of 2022 and spikes in
people unsubbing and we've been on
speaking of fire Dan should do I need to
button this image
uh that might
that might set us back a few steps it's
possible with you but this is basically
in a sense what Howie was doing because
he knows that the people don't like us
and yet he's out there right
why did you have to choose such a
graphic One cam no it is the first one
that came up
that's inappropriate
please send help this is Jesus don't
leave me here
you know what's funny about Jesus they
try to they just act like that's what
they wanted because
it's like when you've Fallen you go I
meant to do that that's what God did
when Jesus died like I meant to do that
foreign
This Thread explores another phenomenon
of Ethan hater's liberals
who are not part of the manosphere Jim
Bros talk who also hate me for example
what a loving liberal
I do feel bad for our fans in a way
because like
it's it is hard to be an H3 fan I feel
like I'm so annoyed that public
procession Ethan is not great this
person said anytime I mention H3 and
people to eat and Ethan and people IRL
they tell me how much they hate him
and they're not even conservatives Alpha
Bros these are just there's just all
kinds of type of people hate Ethan just
venting it makes me upset because I love
Ethan well I love you why am I still
getting hate
that's how I feel
thank you
and um
well this person says everyone I
mentioned h32 has never heard of him so
I'll take the obscurity yeah over the
infamy or better
this person says I feel you people in
the sub seem to think the only it's only
Ultra conservative Alpha bro Peterson
Fanboys that don't like Ethan I'll tell
you I have very little of friends who is
a fallen fan despite having completely
liberal political views some people just
don't like Ethan again I don't follow
the guy and then this person I found
that there are many people who stopped
watching when he said various homophobic
races
or whatever else he may have said
uh right I ran to more people like that
than the gym Bros
see that breaks my heart you know
I think H3 podcast or vh3 podcast
that's crazy that I just it's like
there's another so they made me think
like before
I used to be associated with like
the early manosphere kind of stuff like
having Jordan Peterson on and I think
there was a whole group of people that
were like [__] this
who haven't come back
who thought I was like uh
yeah that whole don't blame people for
not keeping up on the evolution of uh
internet personality that they don't
follow anymore they might not have any
they probably just still think of you
like you were five years ago or whatever
oh I hold it against them oh yeah no
they suck they should burn in hell like
I want them all I want them to burn in
hell dude I was just being polite
um this person says it's because Ethan's
an [__] but he's our [__]
which I like
so I don't know you know it's like uh I
didn't like this guy's Nuance take
because it hurts he said most people I
know who don't like Ethan aren't falling
fans they're just people with a healthy
relationship with the internet who
outgrow YouTube drama okay you [__] off
bro
so I don't know what to do how do I uh
it's but we're making Headway I'm
thinking is there is anything to do
listen I would like for example to have
a month where it's green
well I think we're on our way a month
I've been saying just one month I feel
like we're totally jinxing it right now
by talking about on the show but the the
crew will attest to the fact that
with you not around the last couple
weeks I've been continuously saying we
just need to get through a couple more
weeks wait what do you mean with we've
been not being around
like just during the day when we're
working before you get here when you can
finally uh speak yeah when I can when I
can stop pretending that I like you all
right like all like everybody else on
the internet
no but we've been saying that you know
we're we're on an upswing we got a lot
of good press lately with the Sebastian
thing and right something else that
happened recently that people really
um right I think what really can affect
people is if there's a if you get a
moment a clip a viral moment and people
see it who usually traditionally don't
like you and they say Okay interesting I
did like him in this moment and then you
win them over piece by pieces I looked
them in this moment how do we get more
moments where people like me how do I be
more likable in just one specific moment
I don't think you can I don't think you
can force that I think you know we're
going to talk
we can just keep having uh you know
guests like that where we have call-ins
from people that are hostile I feel like
every time you do have one of those
confrontations it generally goes pretty
good so you know but it's got to kind of
be organic I don't know I I mean I've
told you this before I didn't like you
at your Peak like edginess right you
know I've been reformed thanks to my
friend Lucy Lucy
Lucy We Love Lucy so it's just the
natural process it's a slow building
thing and if this is your first time
watching today feel free to hit that
subscribe button thanks cam good job I'm
Gonna Keep I'm gonna keep plugging it
thanks bro you know there's also well
Frenemies was like this massive
phenomenon I don't know what people
probably people just associated with
internet drama
right which there was a lot of yeah and
a lot of people like that a lot of
people get turned off by it and so I
don't know the show is just
it's evolved a lot over the years and
like you said I mean you've gone through
different shifting eras of like who the
fan base is and not that there aren't
long-term fans that have been loyal
through at all how do I manipulate
people to
following us I don't think you can
manipulate it this comment I like it's
got to be yourself lose weight yeah AV
suggested lose weight very true
um I mean it's sad but on ironically if
you lost 50 pounds I'd probably gain
we'd be green baby we'd be on our way to
the top it's just a sad reality about
the world we live in but yeah
yeah I actually if I got jacked bro
you'd be good forget it how many times
have we seen posts where people were
like oh he's funny but he's fat like
literally that's a deal breaker new
people it's crazy that his wife is ugly
wait wait let me show you what I need to
look like here is the number one
podcaster in the world if only I looked
more like him and less like me
oh yeah is that not photoshopped why
does it live is that photoshopped
I it could be I think it's real life as
well his body's so small that can't be
real his head is the size of his whole
body if you take his head you can and
move it down here it's like the size of
his whole body
I think it might just be the angle of a
photo I don't know yeah I think it's a
fish eye because the ends
get longer I need to look like this
[__]
torpedo man this man is like an Ormond
human torpedo bro
oh [__] his gut is ready to explode
there's so much pressure in there looks
like the underside of a turtle
right
why does it lie he's like a cat what's
the can where they have a dent and
they're starting to Puff out
botulism uh yeah well that's something
that can come from he looks like a
camera you get botulism he's ready to
explode
[__] so that's it that's what it takes
not photoshopped in the chat not that
they're the end-all be-all uh but listen
I'd rather look like that than me in a
Photoshop uh some people look at my body
yeah I mean he looks he looks healthy
well I don't know about healthy but let
me revise that
it looks in shape I guess he looks
muscular yeah maybe not healthy
yeah so I don't know I'm I'm let's see
let's see let's see what happens this
person goes I mean he gets decent views
so people must watch
right so that that's part of the the uh
uh contradiction of our show people yeah
that's been a big part of the reason
that we haven't really I mean we've
obviously had discussions about the fact
that the channel has been bleeding subs
for the last 10 months or whatever it is
but the
the kicker to it has always been yeah
but the views are pretty consistent so
it's like the people that are leaving
aren't the people watching or they unsub
and then they still watched or I'm not
sure exactly what's going on there but
yeah
I think guests will make us grow because
you kind of reach a new a whole new fan
base and like that's what you would
think but
well like when I have guests like they
do get on social
and
yeah I guess I guess it depends on the
guest but yeah yeah
the guest episodes oftentimes are lower
viewed than other episodes but that
doesn't necessarily mean that it's not
getting new eyes it just you know what I
mean like
and then there's a ton of people like I
hate guest episodes
yeah right but sometimes like five
episodes a week right it's like you do
one guest episode and this person can
this person could go [__] die they
said I mean to be fair he has set some
pretty horrible [__] [__] in the past
and I can't get mad at anyone for not
wanting to watch because of that hate
you know what God
laugh if they should suffer
no that's perfectly Fair Point that
they're making [__] Amy's God she's also
died
we'll win them back we'll win him back
Ethan is a guilty pleasure oh God
there it is okay so we're guilty
pleasure we'll get him we'll win him
back we'll win him back we got the
button we got when is that happening
Olivia
the the that guest Friday this Friday we
have an awesome guest
have you ever seen this person do a
podcast before not a podcast no
like a full-on interview
they did a written interview oh wow
that's not even the same you guys are
gonna be so stoked I reached out to this
person who is a comedy icon any Enigma
yeah both fascinating and mysterious
yeah yeah y'all are about to lose your
mind and I am so excited that this
Friday we will be having
I'm proud to announce
without further Ado here we go we are
having Terry Joe
I love Terry Joe
um
she is so funny the he the actor who
portrays Terry Joe Kellen is so funny
they'll both be coming on Friday they
will both be in the studio a two-part
interview a two-part interview exactly
you're gonna do it so
um that sounds freaking awesome I'm
super excited
it's been so requested everywhere too I
see articular comments always suggesting
having them well
see I don't know how to refer well the
actor is a he's so I feel like he you
could say he she I don't know I don't
know what pronouns he is that's what
they told us right they told us Terry is
she her Kellen right the actor is he
yeah yeah
so he is so freaking funny and so it
enigmatic the first time I heard about
him I was doing a members app
and uh someone's like yo you gotta check
out Cherry Joe interview Trisha and I
was like I don't know what that means
and then I tried to find his like
Channel
I couldn't find it because he apparently
he keeps getting banned like he gets
banned like routinely the Wally uh
syndrome yeah Holly p syndrome but he's
interviewing all these he's so funny he
interviews so many funny people and we
actually were we're flying him out we're
putting him up he's gonna be here in
person it's gonna be exciting man
Christian values all the way you know
how I feel about them Christian values
woo
so um
that's great yeah but I understand why
I think part of trying to grow and and
you know accept part of who I am is just
knowing that uh
I accept all the opinions people have of
me I've done all that [__]
you know
and uh we're working on it we're I'm a
work in progress and uh
I'm just trying to stay tuned my true to
myself here and uh always be true to
myself and to always Drew you know say
the right thing at the right time
foreign
and to just be Fearless
yeah that's exciting so
Friday great Friday
moving on
let's see we've got we should uh do our
ad read you talk about stamps.com
I sure am I why don't you tell me a
little bit about stamps.com I'd love to
because stamps.com
oh
okay stamps wait what
when do we get this
uh this was a recent Edition I believe
Zach busted it up for you did you made
this act before Oh no I didn't make it
no no no but it's uh been put on
rotation for the ads wait is this oh
this I thought it was an H3 remix no no
it's
am I crazy that it sounded like it in
the beginning
it's got definitely like a Lo-Fi Vibe
you know yo I love me stamps.com because
as a business owner I understand
that dealing with the post office is
expensive it's time consuming and
it's
it's insane I mean it's so difficult to
manage that relationship
if you're selling stuff online
especially you're going to want to go to
stamps.com
it's absolutely
[Applause]
the greatest service you will ever use
you don't have to think about it you
know champs.com they've been in here for
they've been in business for 25 years
they're helping businesses save time and
money you can focus on your business
knowing stance.com has all the postages
needs covered with premium discounts and
great rates let me tell you about stamps
84 off USPS and UPS rates
that's a premium discount
because they work with millions of
businesses and they're able to negotiate
these insanely low rates
so you're going to be first of all
getting the best rates okay
the convenience is insane let me tell
you how it works
all you need is a computer and a printer
they even send you a free scale so all
you have to do
uh you've got everything you need to get
started all you need is a package pickup
bro I cannot read today
hit the button
if you need a package pickup you can
easily schedule it through your
stamps.com dashboard
and if you sell products
onlinestamps.com seamlessly connects
with every major Marketplace and
shopping cart boom boom
so here's how it works
let's say I gotta print a package go on
to stamps.com
you put it on the scale that they send
you for free it tells you the weight and
the postage exactly you print it up
you put it on the package you tape it on
or glue it on wherever the [__]
and uh
here's the best part you drop it off
or
they'll come pick it up from your
address you can put it in a mail drop
box you can put it at the post office or
they'll just come get it from you don't
even have to think it's cheaper it's
more convenient you literally don't have
to leave your house people
your Ollie uses stamps.com
I don't know if we've ever mentioned
that before on the show well she does
she does
and she loves it right she loves it
she's been using it for years for her
small business that she runs from home
because she sells art and stuff she
sells her art she sends prints she
packages it up in a nice little package
drops it on the scale boom Bob's your
uncle
somebody's here what was the other what
was the size of your uncle and uh can we
recently learned there's a part two of
that
anyways so did she leave it at the in
the mailbox or did she drop it off at
like a drop he'll drop it off most the
time but sometimes she doesn't have time
so she know you know what she does at
that point but has the mailman pick it
up from her do you ever as she's
printing postage be like I saved so much
money with stamps.com literally every
time it drives me nuts she shouts it
you're like excuse me babe 3am horrible
hate when she does that it's exciting
though
is that right Bob's your uncle Fanny's
your auntie
but is it a Banning like a super Bob's
your uncle and Fanny's your aunt wait
Fanny is like very vulgar in English
isn't it
it means like the I've seen other people
say Fanny's your aunt aunt they probably
say it all the time
well anyway
start with stamps.com today if you want
your online business to succeed
sign up at stamps.com h3tv for a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a free digital
skill there's no long-term commitment or
contracts just go to stamps.com
H3 thank you thank you to stamps we love
stamps please support our sponsor thank
you yes we love them don't we
[Music]
mm-hmm
this is pretty good
how he's giving uh Master
roshi Vibes wait Master roshi is like a
turtle shell yeah
I didn't know that
I haven't watched a lot of DBZ I'll be
honest
yeah I forget the Kamehameha has
something to do with the turtle I just
don't remember what it is
okay shout out
hey I found something that's really
[__] interesting I've been calling
this guy out and thank you to Ludwig for
finally exposing the truth about this
guy
this is the lie detector test that's in
every media
collaboration he's been on like Ellen
he's been on like David dobrik James
Charles listen to what Ludwig has to say
about him
and a week after it I I posted the video
with John Grogan that was that was it
that was that was that was how that's
how I did it and then when John came
over initially I thought this was going
to be legit I I I'm being truthful I'm
being truthful John I give him a call he
answers he's like hey it's John Grogan
I'm like hey I need you to film YouTube
videos like it's a thousand dollars I'm
like damn [__] that's kind of more
expensive than the website but also
probably worth it so all right sure a
thousand bucks and then and then he
comes over once he comes over he says to
me look we're not going to be able to do
a legitimate polygraph test here and I'm
like John that's the whole point that's
why I'm paying you a thousand dollars
and he's like yeah okay but a polygraph
test is very slow very boring when you
give an answer I have to read the
results for a little bit before giving a
reply back a lot of the time it's
inconclusive you won't even have a true
uh true or false and it's never an
outright LIE there's just some things
that Trend towards lies and I can't
speak with such you know exact verbiage
I have to be more vague so it's it's
basically a lot Lamer for entertainment
and purposes I was like all right well
that makes sense John so like what are
we going to do he's like well I you know
I can use the system and kind of go by
what it says but
I'm sorry to admit this he said if
there's ever an answer you want
you could tap me on the foot
and if you tap me on the foot that'll
let me know that that should be a lie
and if you don't tap me it'll be a truth
and that's exactly what we did okay
God bless him good Ludwig just exposed
his ass nobody ever exposed him
and I've been guessing that this guy's
been a crooked we tried calling him
right Zach and he wouldn't take our call
uh we reached out to him multiple times
and yeah he uh totally goes to that did
you tell him that you're from H3 podcast
I did yeah yeah
she's probably seen us talking smack
yeah so we had I had such a funny sketch
planned I wanted to have him come on to
do a lie detector test I guess on me and
then as I was setting up I was gonna
have a second real lie detector guy come
in and plug into him
and then I was gonna have a third lie
detector guy plug into the second one
and that's how we get to the bottom I'd
be like yo uh you know do you want to do
uh
you know have you ever lied about uh
clogging the toilet no and then he goes
that's false and then this guy would be
like no
he's lying
I'll be like okay what's going on and
then this guy be like he's telling the
truth
it'd be like a human centipede of lie
detectors there was all different walks
of life we reached out to for this as
well
um there was one guy that was so serious
um saying he was like work for the FBI
for 30 years or something like that and
I I don't know
he was expensive too right what was his
price he wanted like two grand or
something like that but he was like I've
been a part of so many court cases I've
put in criminals away blah blah blah
we're just doing a show brother we're
trying to find like an expert uh witness
or something yeah we didn't actually
Chad is pointing out that Trish is the
one that told me he's a phony so shout
out to her for that but Ludwig really
came out and did it man so this is
awesome and now you can go back and call
so much into question
this man's whole life is alive
and I knew that
here wait where's the one about uh
yo where's the thing about James Charles
that's not in here
No it should be it's in the video bro
this is his website
this is his website he we could get a
hold of him
dial up internet dude you know
are you [__] serious
now is 145 for a complete exam old price
was 3.95.
laugh out loud if an examiner tells you
that a test is more accurate if you pay
more
who would ever say that
certified
36 years of experience that's a lie
there's a reason that TV keeps using
this goon is because he will lie he'll
do whatever you want
oh look it's our boy um
what's his face
Brent Rivera yeah
Grant Rivera
whatever that is
so let me show you something that really
here it is yeah
this is it where's the one with comes
over once he comes over he says to me
look we're not going to be able to do a
legitimate polygraph test here and I'm
like John that's the whole point that's
why I'm paying you a thousand dollars
and he's like yeah okay but a polygraph
test is very slow very boring when you
give an answer I have to read the
results for a little bit before giving a
reply back a lot of the time it's
inconclusive you won't even have a truly
a lot Lamer for entertainment purposes I
was like all right well that makes sense
John so like what are we gonna do he's
like well I you know I can use the
system and kind of go by what it says
but
and I'm sorry to admit this he said if
there's ever an answer you want
you could tap me on the foot
and if you tap me on the foot that'll
let me know that that should be a lie
and if you don't tell me it'll be a
truth
and that's exactly what we did for some
of the answers now some of them
yes
[Applause]
Miguel's want to know did you actually
from Teddy fresh no
no that's true
wow really compelling stuff there James
Charles that's true thumbs up
we're all really really James
oh
next question they all are shocked too
like oh [__] no way exonerated
mm-hmm
that's right it's not shocking but it's
out there
uh Scott Kramer what does that mean
he was the one that initially made the
video exposing this guy and I believe
Ludwig was coming oh he made a whole
last video exposing him John Grogan oh
[__] I mean it is a little [__] up
because well first of all I think it's
important that more people understand oh
this just came out three days ago oh so
Ludwig was responding to this video
saying yeah he lied right I see him
the Dark Truth behind the lie detector
guy
I mean it's not that dark he just lies
for money it's very dark yeah
there it didn't anyway I do think it's
important that people understand that
lie detectors is total pseudoscientific
[__] right
it's not okay how many people actually
believe that this is a real thing
you know
uh and it's not it's not cool kind of
that the guy is kind of [__] his
professional he is kind of uh shell in a
sense
but uh there it is I guess and he's not
even getting paid that much his website
said 136 bucks they'll come lie to you
you could film it
yeah something like that and you know
deep discount too used to be 400.
right desperate times I always had a
grudge against these lie detector guys
because when I was in uh Israel and I
was interviewing for jobs
as a entry-level dude entry level I'm
talking like two thousand dollars a
month for full-time work [__]
and um
they would get make me get a lie
detector test as part of the interview
process that's so weird and it was
normal there in Israel it's humiliating
so you go there I get in a room and he's
asking me like really personal questions
that I don't think is any of their
business
like about my drug use and [__] like
that
right and it's just a bunch of [__]
you know
and the thing is is that
the only way that uh lie detector people
can actually get information is if you
admit it to them that's what they do
they
they try to squeeze you they try to
pressure you by being like I'm sensing
your uh you see like your bra your blood
pressure went up a little bit when you
answered that they go okay I'm sensing
your lying what's really happened that's
how the police do it
someone said he lies for money we should
hook him up to a lie detector that's
what I was gonna do and he [__]
dodged us I was gonna Blitz him I was
gonna have one behind the set they lied
to you well there wasn't it three wasn't
a chain of three I did want three yeah
we could we got two right Zach and then
we got two yes we got two but we didn't
we didn't get the the key one we didn't
get the golden boy right that was gonna
be like a ten thousand dollar sketch too
because those [__]
they really believe in themselves there
was one that only one of the I think
like 500 bucks
to do it that's my guy right there well
apparently you don't need a real lie
detector guy because they'll just say
whatever the [__] you want you might be
our lie detector guy Zach I'm in
thanks should we buy one how much does a
polygraph thing we should how much is it
polygraph test machine oh [__] Andy goes
I cancel my YouTube membership three
minutes later Ethan says April fools
thank God I just renewed it I was so
afraid of that happening Andy
me fast thank you for coming back
I'm telling you man people don't take
prisoners they don't
waited 60 seconds to
turn around and cancel that
um I'm trying
I found like a a shitty USB one on USB
yeah I'm trying to find like a legit one
yeah we need the real deal
I want like an e-meter
would one of you be down to like train
as a polygrapher we could hook up our
guests in the on the polygraph right I
mean I I'd figure out how it works I
mean it's it's [__] right so
what is a lot I can just I can just lie
and pretend here's one ooh one on eBay
from the 1960s 300. that's the one I
want that's what I want yeah
1960s lie detector well that was the uh
it still works it probably doesn't right
that was the Heyday probably the lie
detector this is our Cutting Edge
science it looks pretty legit
I'll keep looking but at the end of the
day the guy's got a nice little business
just being a online personality and but
you all should know
that it's all silliness it's all silly
silly business and James Charles is
actually you know uh using him to refute
serious
accusations and when you see in the
comments his fans were all like gee I
knew he didn't I didn't I knew he didn't
rip it off
as if God himself was like I am the
all-knowing god and I can tell you with
certainty I was there
oh
yeah but I'm loving his website actually
[__] this website is so sick
I [__] can't believe this website is
real
he's got badges even look guys he has
badges
yeah I'm an officer for the Thousand
completed polygraph examinators uh town
he goes when high accuracy is needed due
to millions of viewers here's the
credentials that matter
whoa It's so deep it keeps going oh my
God yo dude this must be regularly
updated oh my God it just keeps going
look at the scroll you can't see the
squirrel bar but this is all okay so is
it looping no no no this is all new
content
to revisit and go deeper what the [__]
wait so let me read one of these if you
need accurate test results read this
secret that several polygraph examiners
don't want you to know
do not test in your home
the federal polygraph Academy strongly
advises to not test in their comfort
zone okay of course going down honestly
why do I need to know any of that
information though because he he wants
to show you that he's an expert
bro this is the craziest website I've
ever seen it's psychotic look at I'm
just telling let me keep scrolling
this is all different stuff do you see
how long this is I'm almost like I'm
seeing some repeats in there oh my God
no find a repeat
and there's definitely repeats but it's
looks randomized yeah
I saw I saw a graph that I swear I saw
before so you think of this [__]
your polygraph consumer warning and
alert number one click here to learn
this rocks the equipment secrets so
that's another factor that was talked
about in this video I guess is that he
has about 50 websites and he's strong
arming other people other um lie
detector dudes into leading to his
websites
yeah but nobody's going to this website
and hiring him
he's even been with Howard
who how is everyone hiring this question
have you tried to this is how we found
it I mean this is yeah we we did the
same thing so [__] wouldn't answer
yeah dude you went through all this
effort to get a call and he wouldn't
answer us [__] we called him 20
follow him right now call him right now
so we literally sorted through don't
like play it for the radio or the the
video
I just want to know if he answers all
right hold on I gotta find his number I
want to get him in here man oh he's
probably getting
he's probably laying low though after
that video interview Prospect what's it
like for the lie detector guy after his
downfall yes I wanted the exclusive I
think that'd be awesome you want me to
call him on air you want me to go step
up no no don't play it on air because
that's not legal okay without his
consent
it's okay if we hear like if you stay
there
you know
we should get the exclusive interview
yeah he's he's probably laying low after
he got exposed
how you doing uh this is this is uh Zach
from the H3 podcast
the H3 podcast we contacted you a few
months ago about uh possibly coming on
our show
yeah
um we're wondering if you'd like to uh
come on and stop by for an interview
um when are you available
step away step away step away do it do
it away
okay
he didn't answer he didn't answer for so
long and now we got him
that's God maybe the calls have dried up
after the uh yeah he's a little more
desperate that's probably why the
discount the Steep discount right that
discounts I've been recently canceled
here's a fat discount do you think he
links the Ludwig vid right here this is
the video where I got canceled Scott
Kramer expose look at this he has
polygraph comics
Frank did you spend the whole of our
monthly budget on renting a polygraph
yes
why would you do that
there he is given that that's true he uh
he hung up on me
oh for real yeah he's like I can't talk
right now uh don't go call me back when
I'm at my office and then he hung up
uh he's going through it probably but he
sounded down to come on possibly dude
this dude worked so hard to get the call
look at this website
look I'm still scrolling this is the
same [__] page
I'm gonna go all the way down to the
bottom
controlling so far is so fast too like
I've never seen a website like this in
my whole life
rocks
this is weird need to rent a four red
polygraph equipment polygraph instrument
from producers can usually choose from
analog or computerized click here are
you talking about this one that's like
a hundred swipes down
okay let's click here
rent a polygraph
this is crazy
I'd never seen a website like this in my
whole life here's Bryce our boy friend
of the show killed Anna oh I guess it's
kill of Kiss
[__] me dude
I found like five similar websites it's
just as I say besides they're all the
same style right and they all lead back
yeah this is his website okay this is
his video this is interesting hi guys
it's John TV's lie detector guy I've
been on over a thousand YouTube shows
social media shows and TV shows if you
need me to help you with something you
can look at the website
polygraphrental.com or certified
polygraph.com
or TV YouTube Tick Tock Instagram and
more
no I I want to say
I think it's kind of [__] up that we
don't need to expose uh the Youtube
polygraph guy like we don't need like a
whole hour long clip about the dark side
of the polygraph guy that's what kind of
sucks is because like we know that it's
all silly [__]
but the creators portray it as this like
serious ass thing
I don't know I just I feel bad for him
because he's definitely going through
some [__] and it's like yeah dude she's
just she's doing shtick for goddamn
shows
maybe he's got to know the difference
between doing it for Jimmy Kimmel and
then doing it for like uh
you know
Tick Tock [__]
influencer [__] what's the difference
the difference is the influencer [__]
is going to
use it not responsibly and also going to
snitch on you
where I guess maybe if you do Jimmy
Kimmel and he's like yeah I'll do
whatever you want right they're not
going to be like oh this guy's a [__]
phony liar the dark side
I don't think ah [__] I'm surprised he
actually went for this long though
without getting busted
[__]
most content creators on the various
platforms such as YouTube Tick Tock and
the others they find when they do a
polygraph episode they actually get more
views more views we've done hundreds of
YouTubers you can go to youtube.com and
type in lie detector you'll see almost
all the videos involve me
that's true okay that's true how did
this guy that's true the whole damn
vertical he owns it look at this [__]
this is where you [__] up bro look
just look at this image
dug too deep he's amazing
carpool karaoke
it was at this moment that he knew he
[__] up this man put his whole goddamn
life on this page
there's got to be other polygraph people
in the world
I mean there are but this he's ruthless
he's a ruthless competitor you think
yeah just a ruthless business owner well
he's got like 15 websites that are all
like
polygraphtest.com get a
polygraphtest.com it's like every
iteration of that you could he's a
multi-millionaire from the [__] you
think so he doesn't charge that much I'm
just yeah
okay wait I hate to tell you guys so I
went all the way down and it just the
bar now just reset so there's more I
think it's just an endless but I've
never reached the bottom
oh he got to the bottom he said no reset
it restarted well you just haven't
they're gone all the way down I'm gonna
go all the way down okay here's the
bottom footprint is crazy this is the
bottom
Jimmy Kimmel Live what year is this from
Brother
1800. this is 20 years ago he said
it's got the same look too
he has an age today
these frames are really speaking to me
dude
this is [__] awesome here's a
playlist let's see
lie detector guy
300 Subs
this is a rabbit hole I did not plan to
go down today to be totally honest with
you guys
I'm John I'm a polygraph examiner I've
tested over 8 000 people I see one of
them lying I will let you know God hates
Liars Liars God hates Liars okay
all right John you [__] are you
serious he said I hate liars and God
does too
tired and I hate liars oh my God the
more I see the more I admire him
honestly he's a player bro Jesus
this guy has built quite a career for
himself
God hates liars and I [__] hate liars
more
I can sniff him out and tell you with
100 certainty oh
I'm John I'm a polygraphic oh this is
the one
facts and secrets
okay let's see how up front he is
um hi do you need a polygraph test in
Santa Clarita since the 1980s we've been
testing in Santa Clarita Saugus
surrounding areas wow
before calling us New Hall we should go
out to new homes
Antelope Valley the whole Antelope
Valley I love that instead of degrees
behind him he has license plates that
say polygraph this is called credential
he has credentials right there this is
what it looks like guys
it's the Matrix you can kind of read it
if you know what you're looking at but
uh
first let me introduce myself you
already did that
John it's certified polygraph.com
I've been doing polygraphs since the
1980s they're tested more than 11 000
people I've been on hundreds and
hundreds of TV show episodes
I've been on more than 600 million views
of various social media wow let me
answer some of the common questions that
people call about polygraph four
how accurate okay here's your
opportunity to tell us the truth mess up
how accurate
basically I don't it's not really at all
it's just why does it lie it's an end
okay let's hear what he says let's see
what he says probably the most common
question we get is how accurate is
polygraph go ahead John let me give you
some real world information in
California you can't become a cop
without passing a lie detector test okay
is that true
I mean that doesn't mean that it's good
that means that just means a lot our
system is sad as [__] this guy's the
reason the LAPD are so corrupt I was
about to say this is actually a good
explanation did you shoot that man on
purpose or was it an accident that's
true no no
ask chat gbt maybe how how reliable are
polygraph tests okay and join the FBI or
any other federal agencies so there's
two levels of accuracy number one it's
medical equipment reading your Blood
Sweat and breathing it's a hundred
percent accurate as far as that goes bro
stop it
then the second level of accuracy is
what we do when we take what we've
learned from Those sensors usually our
calls are held to be about 95 percent
accurate
95 percent accurate
uh on the website joinlapd.com they do
list as one of the steps a uh polygraph
examination
yeah you know crazy now the FBI still
polygraphs people
right but like you said like I could see
it like you were describing using it as
part of an interrogation tactic but to
interview potential hires for the police
department what the [__]
so here's what chat this is for right
Amy
uh 3.5 is an idiot doesn't know I don't
think it's going to give the same kind
of answer no I swear to God it's totally
different
because it knows everything we already
know that they're not real I want to
hear what the bot says okay well you can
get Dan has a login just you can log in
for you you got to use Four Brothers
access to he has the same access as
everybody else but at the top there
should be a click down reliability of
lie detectors I see it you can click it
and then GPS up to four yeah because 3.5
is just like a [__] idiot it's just a
moronic stupid low brain okay no
reasoning power at all all right I'm
asking I'm asking for right now
you want to wait for this go ahead go
ahead go ahead
lie detector test also known as
polygraph death are designed to measure
physiological responses such as heart
rate blood pressure I didn't ask what is
it well this is four you were so
insistent on four this is what four game
he has a tendency to over explain or
they I should say there are several
factors that can affect the accuracy of
a lie detector test one test conditions
the accuracy of the test can be
influenced by factors such as the
environment right he pointed that out
test subjects Behavior some individuals
might be able to manipulate their
physiological responses or exhibit
behaviors that make it difficult for the
examiner to interpret the results
accurately number three test
interpretation the interpretation of
results can be used by this robot sucks
yeah
ask it this if you squeeze your butthole
can you if you squeeze your butthole can
you um can you trick a polygraph yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yes
okay
it has to say
the idea of using the countermeasures
like squeezing one's muscles including
the buttocks to trick a polygraph test
has been discussed and debated the
theory behind this technique is that
creating a physiological response
unrelated to lying can potentially
confuse the examiner and disrupt the
reading making it harder to determine if
someone who is being deceptive however
the effectiveness of such techniques is
unclear and likely depends on various
factors such as the skill of the
examiner the quality you're not getting
this past John
see this robot sucks this robot's a
shelf
they're sitting on the fence just say
this listen just give me a percentage
just tell me is this real yes or no give
it to me
no [__] you don't no [__]
you know I'm not asked for our polygraph
tests
uh accurate or Dependable or not
dependable
short answer short answer you idiot stop
with bot explaining love that that's so
good over explaining you
[__] [__]
okay here we go
chat TBT is ruining H3 Daniella said
here we go polygraph tests are not
completely dependable and can produce
both false positives and false negatives
that's all you had to say
Where Do We Begin Electronics were first
uh invented in the 1920s since then
there's been lots of evolution
people are still coming in and thinking
we're going to uh Spotify
but I guess that's the power of that
April Fool the little old timey joke I
guess we should just say every 20
minutes or so we are not moving to
Spotify it was an old-timey kind of
April fools type of thing
you understand you waka waka waka waka
we got you
yeah but I don't know what do you think
this guy's probably in in a real [__]
storm right now with all these little
[__] on the internet just giving him
[__] surprise he took my call like us
not like us I mean it's literally us are
you talking about you spent 45 minutes
I'm giving him a little Grace I'm giving
him a little Grace I just think his
website's silly
he's doing shorts you guys
I didn't really appreciate him saying
God hates Liars when you are proof of me
crazy
God does hate liars Dan
this website is giving me life though
it's
it's quite excellent yeah
all right let me just go to the top here
he is with impulsive yeah he's done it
all folks let me go all the way to the
top just to see show you guys what's
going on here
[__] me
uh
yeah yeah
all right it's I'm not even close
see what I sent in Discord so lie
detector guy is canceled
oh no
guys took a lie detector test today we
are back in the hot seat and we are
going to put our friendship did they
test the cheating guy let it play right
now yo to the test oh my God Ned are
there any secrets that you're hiding
from us I don't think so that's a lie oh
boy so maybe he's legit you got you
buddy he got you on that one another
um
should have listened
9.3 million it's true that guy brings in
views man
[Music]
yeah but if you're someone out there
that's looking for a job just buy one of
these things and just tell people you
you're like yeah I don't know [__]
true
just pretend like you're looking true I
guess yeah
right yeah this does that mean true or
false it means fault the false was it's
a positive on the false
a thumb is worth a thousand words yep
that's right
okay there it is
[Music]
so you called him Zach and then he was
like it could work I'm not in my office
and then hung up correct
he didn't say call me back he didn't say
anything oh I said can I call you later
he's all yeah yeah call me later and did
he answer just like hello or was he like
hey this is the office of lie detector
guy or whatever he said this is John so
it's okay interesting yeah
I wonder if it's his personal phone too
this is John
I mean we could set it up if you know I
do definitely want to get him in the
studio at all costs okay I will pay him
anything I want to interview him I'm
gonna talk to him I want to know him I
want to know who he is I know who made
that website okay we'll set it up
thank you
moving on Mark Elliott friend of the
show Nexium cult member who cured his
Tourette's because he's not a [__] have
a good night his words not mine yeah
hey man the [__] up he man the [__] uh
man the [__] up and stop shaking
stop shaking what do you oh so they're
still talking about me
actually they have they created a whole
podcast about me him and his homie make
Justice blind
it would be good for Ethan Klein to
reconsider his statement about Mark
Elliott okay yeah you and the two likes
[__] eight the 84 people that saw
this are all
rub a lamp
wait what does that mean
that's one hidden comment just rub a
lamp have a good night
[Laughter]
God okay so here's the club you wish it
certainly sounds like it ask a genie
I've just never heard that I like it
though go rub a lamp
all right here we go even though Ethan
might not see Hope on you know people
being able to use mind over body to
overcome diseases that are like
Tourette's and others I do think that
there's hope of him retracting what he
said and doing the right thing he said
something very strong very damaging
about you that there is proof of the
opposite and at the very least you can
go and watch an hour of a movie and then
make another stage which I'm not
watching an hour you crazy I got two
kids I usually watch an hour
I already talked to him for an hour all
right and I think that I call that hope
because if he doesn't do it then you
know we know what we have you know one
more person that just it spreads false
information and doesn't care you know
gets no accountability like our
immediate sue me then
sue me for defamation
today take a number
but if he does you know it gives it
gives a lot of other people the
possibility that they can also do that
and our media of today needs that even
though Ethan so then you went and
followed the thread apparently they have
a podcast
right that it's just all clips about me
the podcast that they do from the uh
padded uh rooms of the insane asylum
apparently let's see make Justice blind
um
where do they post their [__]
makejusticeplain.com it's just a okay
now we're going back to YouTube it's
this one all right the dersh yeah with
the dersh
but see it's not listed it was unlisted
the Twitter account is almost all clips
about you
Twitter all right so let's take a look
here so there's this one
and today oh so yeah here's the other
one about me in today's world
uh people can influence through social
media sadly many influential media
people like Ethan Klein from HD podcast
can say whatever they want without
supporting their claims here is a clip
with two people in it and two likes
I'm telling we know who are the two
people that like this we can see
why don't you click on it and find out
oh okay good idea wait you can click on
the tweet
and then click online yeah right right
right
so let's see this looks like potentially
him okay and I do not let people [__]
with me oh that's not dark okay robot
land brutal thinking on cult and
anti-cult this is the guy who liked it
interesting
um that's Mark Elliott
shit's weird Brothers you can't be
thought in as a journalist it's more of
a podcast it's a different style but
when you can reach three million people
just that that makes you sort of a
journalist in in not at all no no that's
not right what is that at all everybody
yeah LeBron James he's a little bit of a
journalist people now here brother yeah
nice try idiot ability you can't just
say anything I believe I guess I should
clarify I just wouldn't call him a good
journalist no I wouldn't either you
wouldn't call him a journalist at all I
wouldn't even consider myself one like
the guy on a comedy podcast he's a bad
journalist that he declined
[__] idiot AdSense yes but you're
right he's he has a standard he didn't
watch one one hour if you didn't watch
one hour
of a movie where that thing is like
exposed the thing that he's going to
talk about and then spoke to 3 million
about it with an opinion that's very
strong Well it's worse because I told
him
I cannot believe the circle character
there nobody's even watching this no
one's watching this this is sad talk
about not doing preparation brother you
[__]
gotta look in the mirror there mark
even I I did send him an email saying
please watch this video that shows my
transformation of overcoming Tourette
syndrome and then he goes to three
million people and says the exact
opposite yeah and most likely 2.8 and
you say what million people thank you
did we get that many no that's how many
Subs the channel has I assume oh that's
why they're saying three million okay I
don't think he got that many views no
well he's out of journalist I love this
man these guys are my fave
so let's keep going I'm just curious
what else do they have to say so I'm not
a journalist that hit that hurt you know
that hurt me that's rough buddy Nexium
tampering H3 here's another one Mark
Elliott was on the H3 podcast to discuss
the FBI interference
yeah this one only got one like
tough crowd huh
saying X and I'm saying look we need to
be able to question that that's a very
sensitive controversial thing for most
people to talk about but the the thrust
of what I was on there was talking about
there are seven digital forensic experts
four former four former FBI talking
about that there is conclusive evidence
that shows that the government
participated in tampering to convict a
U.S citizen great why are you talking
about on the History Podcast and not in
court if you got the evidence you should
be really easy to exonerate them I mean
I kept asking him really simple question
I was like okay fine they they put the
child p word on his computer what about
the gajillion other charges he goes uh
uh uh we can talk about that too if you
want but I I I have a good night have a
good night yeah you're right they're all
clips about me holy [__] Ethan Klein was
dishonest uh
Ethan Klein from H3 podcast
rub a lamp dude yeah just rub a lamp get
over it rub a [__] lamp make three
wishes this one he's he's complaining
about I wasn't honest again bro not to
rehash old drama butt our email exchange
was beautiful he reached out and all I
said was
I'd love to have you on the show here's
Dan to schedule that was it
I only ever when I was coordinating with
him it was like one sentence emails I
kept it I did it on purpose because I
didn't want to mislead him yeah
I mean you can say all you want about
you know I walked into a trap which
clearly I did but I was very clear with
my intentions about going on the show
yeah you reached out to us you reach out
to us dum-dum we didn't invite you on
you literally came and asked to come on
the show idiot how do you think it
happened oh I said hey my name is Mark
you don't walk into a trap he he set up
a trap for himself and then stuck his
foot in it it's like I went up to Isis
headquarters knocked on the door
and and said what you know and then they
they cut my head off and I didn't
understand why I was in The Vow I'm I
want to come on to talk about the
tampering in the case of U.S versus
Ranieri there's nothing deceptive about
what I was trying to do where here Ethan
knew that that was the case of what my
intent was and then he based my
understanding is he the coping here is
fantastic this is this is like
incredible stuff man oh [__] this is so
good
the implication was he's inviting you to
talk I did not invite him
did we ever pull up the email exchange I
think it's worth showing yeah
right yeah right yeah we we covered all
of it yeah which I did talk about those
things on there great but the point of
him having me on I think for him was to
set me up in a trap to make me look like
an idiot so I don't think he was really
being honest about why he wanted to
never on the show I knew
idiot it wasn't to actually have uh a
dialogue and have sort of this adverse
this man literally cut dialogue into two
look at how he did dialogue Weight
Watchers dial
ogue oh log that's weird right I've
never seen anybody do that log log
dialogue what's a dial log dialogue and
have sort of this what is a dialogue
adversarial conversation but very
difficult things I mean you can say oh
these guys are [__] awesome this is
so
so satisfying
I'm sorry Mark I was hoping I got
through to you but uh Mark comments on
the false accusations made against him
by H3 this is really something you're
you weren't kidding Kim it's all about
me
just more people out in the world to
hate me
people Mark me to girl on uh
Tinder she'd be like I'm a huge fan of
History Podcast he's like oh I hate you
you'd be like how can I have a good
night have a good night I feel bad that
one like that it got seems to be a fan I
think they may have liked it by accident
because a bunch of their likes are like
the podcasts and stuff oops whoopsies or
maybe they just thought rub a lamp
rub a lamp this is from one minute ago
but I think he I think it's all rub a
lamp from here on out guys
oh God
rub a lamp everybody
here let's see
have a good night L rubber lamp Rubble
lamp rub a lamp emoji
[Laughter]
it's gonna be so confused a big Burn
yeah they're gonna be so confused
oh
more confused than they already are
uh Berkeley thing for the 10 gifted you
know I will say to everyone tuning in we
are not moving to Spotify that was April
Fool's gag little old timey one we had a
little fun at the top of the show
had a little bit of a couple laughs
probably kill there bladed uh
April Fool's joke there for you guys
thanks for tuning in
hey we got a new oh [__] did we not
watch this one the preacher demonstrates
how to polish a pole
didn't we watch this on Friday
I I don't think so I think we did didn't
we did you guys see this of course
there's fire horses we we had Iraq what
you watched it on the membership oh okay
somebody in members chat sent me this by
the way members uh podcast is tomorrow
for all members thank you very much love
you guys this was sent to me last
Tuesday
this shit's unreal now I don't think
it was intended to be sexual
somehow
but here is uh if he's a preacher I
would assume so yeah Jack chap
s of course there's fire cautious pain
cautious
shut up I can handle it I know what I'm
doing I know what I'm doing oh oh that
hurts oh oh God I'm so tired oh God I
didn't want to lose her oh God that's
what I was saying like he doesn't does
he really not know what he's doing he
knows exactly what he's doing
but he's a preacher he's a holy man he
wouldn't be the first preacher he's
horny as [__] it with 37 feet of cement
potion
I think he's doing some analogy about
polishing the rod is about faith in God
you have to keep polishing the rod I
don't know the beginning
he just busted
come on
[Music]
and but look how intense the old the guy
on the left is uh he is locked in he's
locked the [__] in they're taking this
super serious not even a smile on any of
their faces
oh my gosh yeah
beautiful wife
yeah I never dreamed of her
a lot of things you never dreamed of I
never dreamed of her lots of things you
never dreamed of oh you think I could
marry her
very very polished
you better get more polish done
oh my God here's a cup here's a comment
being raised fundamental Baptist this
was the closest thing I ever had to sex
education
he's rubbing the lamp is what he's doing
yeah
from what I know about uh
some uh strains of Baptist that does
actually track make sure they serve me
this is how it's done boys rub we gotta
polish the lamp
you know
rub a lamp here gentlemen the comments
on this post are saying that this guy
went to prison oh for real talking to a
17 year old no no way no no no no no no
no no way any facts I need articles
what's his name Jack shap C hap
s-c-h-a-a-p
s-c-h-a-a-p c h a a p a c s c h a a p uh
well he's out now prison releases former
First Baptist Church Pastor so glad he's
after serving nine years for sexually
abusing an underage girl no [__] sh
I'm shocked
I am shocked
that a Southern Baptist preacher would
sexually abuse someone so embarrassing
it's funny but it's also like
when
it's just really sad because like it's
so not surprising yeah and these people
are doing a tour about uh pointing
fingers about who's sex criminals and
stuff yeah really sad
well there we go polishing the shaft
there it is we got a new I'm gay sound
drop that's really good from Pink
um pink decided to make her acceptance
speech for the Human Rights Campaign
Ally for equality
and uh she was trying to make a point
into the making the crowd think she was
a lesbian to make a point about
normalizing sexuality it didn't land in
my opinion I'm gay
[Applause]
actually I'm not
I know that clip like a song the way
that I like know all the beats and
everything I said it with her so what is
the deal here she she's I'm gay
she was like I'm with you I am gay like
everyone else I'm gay I'm black
essentially actually I'm not
but then so why'd she have to pull it
back she's almost like ew Psych well she
didn't want to lie
you're gay
she's yeah
I'm gay
that's what she said
okay actually I'm not actually I'm not
I'm gay that's [__] interesting so
there it is Zach uh we got that one to
the repertoire I'm gay
today I feel uh yeah she was gay
basically saying that she wants to live
in a world where the same response is
saying I'm gay is the same as saying
like Oh I'm a Pisces or something that's
confusing man yeah
again I mean it's hard enough I guess to
be gay and to date and stuff and now
you've got all these straight people
walking around saying they're gay I mean
it's confusing okay
no I'm not gay I was just saying it in
solidarity
but being gay and being black is
different
I agree I don't know why those aren't
real why would God make let's begin and
gay men why what was the purpose of that
speaking of that sound bite we got a
part two of that clip that we missed
actually I'm not wait what which part
two from the uh Jesse Lee Peterson yeah
oh there's a second part yeah right here
oh [__] I love him so much how old are
you uh 68. so are you gonna be like gay
all your life or with this class
you know you know the answer to that as
well as I do but you're going to be
black all your life or is it going to
pass but being gay or being black is
different it's like no it's not my
brother that is a skin color but gay is
like a lifestyle is that what you
believe yeah you can overcome it no I'm
afraid that's uh that's wrong uh so
while we're here to talk about sacred
resistance we're going to talk about man
you did not know what show you were
going on this is like Mark Elliott
walking into a lion's den well he's
conducting himself a lot better at least
did you expect to have a serious
conversation with this man
I'm just telling that you're gay I
didn't know that I didn't read it one
last question about that why would God
make lesbians and games what was the
purpose of that let's begin why did God
make zebras
what was going on
to multiply to make more sense why do we
need more zebras to keep the earth clean
and do what zebras do
but you don't know why God made no I
don't know why God made zebras I don't
know why God made you or why God made me
amazing if you say amazing being a
little presumptuous no he may
create love
and he probably made zebras to make to
so that's why he made gay people amazing
I'm really I had no idea
[Music]
I love him he's just so [__] Wild
I'm rude I had no idea
um
that's the best why is it mind-blowing
that's my wrong
actually I'm not
he's so mind-blowing that he's gay let's
begin
um what's this one Mega awesome nerd
made something cool for us oh yeah for
the button screen oh okay I see so if we
push the button this might pop up
I won't have the sound though
oh cool
it's already been added it's time to get
canceled that's awesome
Mega awesome nerd what a legend hey we
got an overlay we should hit him with it
you got that one back there Ian yeah
it's just an April Fool's joke guys a
little old-timey
[Music]
uh we're not going to Spotify we would
never do that actually
what clown you are I know sorry
everybody but it's chocolate mocha just
a joke
[Music]
um let's see here
oh [__] I've been wanting to watch this
one this this when the grooms
wait what
wait
what happened
do I really gotta watch this guy talk
over it
said this earlier in the wedding day
anything you want to say oh Heath wait
he filmed this I put it online yes
that's a little crazy
he filmed their wedding
first of all what the guy said is nuts I
agree but this man asked their
photographer went to their wedding
filmed it and then put it online that's
crazy and he it makes me doubt the whole
thing I think it's fake now I didn't
realize that
that doesn't make any no professional
would do that you think it's fake it
seems so real well let's watch and see I
didn't think that at all until you just
pointed that out and now immediately I
think this whole thing staged I did not
know that groom said this earlier in the
wedding day I won't lie when the groom
said this
I was shocked that was definitely me
that was me and you want to say to your
future Brian
I hope we have a lot of sex that's fake
a lot that's fake I should have known
his dolls were gonna go like this oh my
God it is fake yeah this thing is all
[__] see I never saw the part me
neither him I only saw
yeah dude you faked it bro I'm fed up
and exhausted look at all this fake
[__] okay
oh my God this is mind-blowing
okay well watch this only two things are
required to keep me happy keep my belly
full and my balls empty
so you're amazing at half of it we
really need to get you some cooking
lessons
even when my belly is in full there is
no one I could ever love more in this
lifetime unless I actually get a chance
to meet Margot Robbie
since the beginning I was always told
she does it looks so real in this moment
like the pain is suffering it's all
there
the humiliation the it's all adding up
for me
[Music]
it's it's that I'm so confused now my
life gets even better when the kids fall
asleep and you tell me to come to the
bedroom
nothing's better than the sound of
gagging and headboard slamming Michael
PS since you're so good at making
decisions like marrying me you can
choose whether tonight's gonna end with
being a toaster strudel or a Twinkie
people wouldn't laugh would they I mean
they might I don't know that is horrific
being that I am his mom I will deal with
him later he is grounded by all means
what do we think it's an old-timey
wedding there's more videos after this
of the ceremony if that helps because if
this guy said leaked this
that's [__] nuts
yeah that's like the easy way to lose
your business forever like you're a
professional videographer you shoot
weddings I can't wait to get pregnant
you're just like look at these [__]
weirdos that I think I just shot okay
well let me look at this it doesn't add
up it doesn't make sense okay I'm
looking back at his previous content and
here he shoot he has content of other
weddings
and let's let's just watch one of these
and see if it feels real
[Music]
uh post ceremony walk
he's trying to promote his business
right that's that's what I figured but
these are real I don't see these being
weird or
let's see this one got on a viral moment
room cries when he sees his bride I mean
whatever
okay
let's see the other Clips here so this
one went super viral
Michael is giving now a kitchen
okay that's her
oh she said there's a comment from her
she says so I'm the bride
and and this isn't a red flag we have
been together for 10 years now and
decided to get married right before our
10th year
girl that's a red flag
I mean what like it's their wedding if
they have that kind of sense of humor
with them each other and their friends
that's fine it's it don't like if it if
it's just like a private thing like
nobody needed to ever see this outside
of like that close group of people it's
possible he asked for permission he says
do my guys mind if I post this to my
tick tock
yeah but even like yeah it's funny go
for it yeah yeah maybe so the bride
actually responded in a tick tock of her
own I linked it in Discord so okay this
this this is interesting let's see what
she had to say about this
so if you've seen the vows on Tick Tock
that have now gone viral
not bride
so with that being said yes I'm happy
yes I'm still married yes I love my
wedding and there is nothing that I
would have changed I loved his vows I
love my vowels he loved his vows okay
girl what does it mean I know what it
means to be a if he's she he said you
get to choose if you want to be a
Twinkie or a toaster strudel I know what
he means by Twinkie because it's cream
filled but what is it what does he mean
by toasters
ew dude [__] nasty as [__] dude there
it is that is so dirty in front of your
mom
so the only CH so your own the only
choice you'll be naked making tonight
babe is if you want to get creampied or
facialized from everywhere in my room
which is
definitely Michael
my Val showed my size a little bit of my
personality which is not outspoken like
Michael fairy too it's like you said Dan
if so I think it's real right do we
change back to being real now it might
be real just the framing of all of it
seems very sus that I don't know why
would she make this video she's like
here she's a real person
[Music]
I think it's real man
and I think it's like you said
if this was just a private event and
they know each other and it was all fun
and they have a good relationship that's
awesome but the fact that that got cut
and put on Tick Tock this guy's probably
getting [__] on tickets
because he looks like such a freak dude
here this one is 26 when the Grimm said
this earlier when the groom said this
I was shocked that's the original yeah
since the day we started talking after
okay here's more contacts that's
actually so sad though because he only
talked about her physically and not that
he loves her or anything like that so
here's the full thing let's take a look
let's take a look Dan
let's see if there's love in it or if
it's just [__] or face
Twinkie or strudel yeah
Tick Tock is not playing you know what
band Tick Tock I'm over it
particularly show embarrassing me yeah
this program since the day we started
talking after falling through my bedroom
window within minutes I could tell you
were the one for me then as time went on
and I was falling deeper in love with
you I wasn't always the minute I saw
them fat titties I knew you were the one
for me
oh yeah love seeing those things flop
[__]
I mean
just it's not really that different than
when the stuff he says the [__] he said
is more vile yeah
as well be one of the easiest people to
please only two things are required to
keep me happy keep my belly full and my
balls empty that's so you're amazing bro
that's just crazy that's just crazy yeah
half of it we really need to get you
some cooking lessons
even when my belly isn't full there is
no one I could ever love more in this
lifetime unless I actually get a chance
to meet Margot Robbie like that's also
crazy
like it's the one point to it being fake
is that the way it's written is like the
most insanely offensive [__] up in
every way possible
since the beginning I was always told I
always told you I was going to make you
the happiest woman in the world and give
you everything I could possibly give
well today I'm taking a step further and
giving you my last name the last name of
Champions
Jesus performance is just not there for
me yeah you could have sold it better I
mean the material is one thing but the
delivery is a little monotone the
material is blowing online because that
was just self-congratulatory and there's
no there's not yet been one [__] nice
thing he said about her
no one deserves it more with you and the
girls by my side I feel like I can
conquer anything
y'all make life worth living giving
Every Breath of every day of purpose
life gets even better when the kids fall
asleep anytime you're going to the
bedroom
nothing's better than the sound of
gagging and headboard slamming dude
that's insane
that's like insane he says they have
daughters their daughters are there you
think the dot they're there right I mean
they would be probably
gagging and head gagging
everyone keeps telling me that marriage
is going to ruin a lot of things but I
feel that's only if you let it even if
we fight argue or don't see eye to eye
on something it'll never affect the way
I love you
marriage is something I take seriously
and I only want to do once after almost
10 years I still stand by the fact that
you're my soul mate and it'll never
change
after today okay touching soul mates
I can't nothing will make me think
you're not my soul mate now get on your
knees and gag on my [__]
they're the only thing changing is me
having to deal with the ring on my
finger
he will forever have my heart and that's
a promise till death do it apart P.S and
you're so good at making decisions like
marrying me you can choose whether
tonight's going to end with being a
toaster strudel or a Twinkie
dude that is [__] insane
like just having the ability to write
something so vile is
dude holy [__]
this man better never leave her
I'm speechless
in front of your mom really
I think it's true that I am his mom I
will do that with him later he is
grounded by all means
I think it's real I think the guys out
there doing his thing well they've been
together for 10 years so clearly they're
making it work God bless them got some
kids together you know yeah
didn't need to see that
jacket off I don't think he knows what
valves are is the tough comet
oh [__] dude all right well there it is
so that's our boy
lots of conversations that we had some
debate some questions
who thinks it's real by show of hands
we've got lots we've got hands Abby are
you up he's up
I mean I you it might be real I don't
know I I just feel like the whole like
framing of it is kind of disingenuous
it's still throwing me off well the
photographer definitely [__] them over
if it's real like blocked them over
I will say that I noticed both this
account and the wife's account had a lot
of videos on it so maybe I think it was
actually real but maybe the intent was
to be
to go viral I mean that's kind of what I
meant by like fake why would he want
he's like yo I'm just a private person
I'm not even trying to be an influencer
that's what AB is saying is that it
might not be the case that they are
trying oh but they're just but they're
not like videos when I see their videos
it's just people like posting normal
[__] they're not trying to become like
viral that's that's not what I see when
I look at them because a lot of people
use tick tock casually like you know
Facebook just kind of like sharing with
their friends and stuff
I think everybody on tick tock's trying
to be famous
right
I mean she has 7 000 followers she's
well that's probably from the right the
reason exactly I feel like going viral
on Tick Tock is like turned into a game
like everybody at least has
if if you are active on Tick Tock one of
your videos is gonna get picked up I
feel like
and especially if you're trying okay
maybe maybe gosh to me it's like I don't
want to be known as this most disgusting
vile man alive right I mean they don't
think that they think it's funny they
were cracking up the whole time okay
just it's just it looks she looked kind
of like she was hiding her pain a little
bit but uh
okay maybe maybe you guys are right
you know
I think he's just like that I do I do
but whatever what do I know but anyway
there it is shut up uh let's hit him
with the overlay real fast Ian
it's a quick update update Guys April
fools we are not moving through Spotify
just a little bit of a gag there for
y'all at the belated April Fool's Day
gag
thank you
I gotta go to the bathroom so freaking
bad maybe do a poll while I go to the
bathroom I'm not taking a pause like is
it
staged
oh oh about the video Yeah stage uh real
or real with the intent to go viral
stage real
real but with intent
to go viral
okay
throwing it up you know what I think
what do you think cam I think I'm gonna
see Zach Lewis live at the son of a
[__] uh what is it April May May 13th
It's gotta be sold out by now right
we're getting close dude you've been
saying that for a month we're getting
close that doesn't I don't believe you
anymore we're getting close
you've been saying you've been getting
close we're getting closer guys we're
getting close we're getting close almost
there
also
while we're plugging Creator Clash is in
12 days yeah that's creatorclash.com
sure God bless
you gonna win yeah [__] yeah he's gonna
win all right then I'm buying a ticket
thank you but if you're not gonna win I
don't want to watch that I don't want to
watch my friend AB get beat up he's not
gonna
you're gonna watch him win then I'm more
then I'm there buy a ticket I think
we're doing another uh watch party for
those of you out there that saw the
the watch party last time I was watching
from college with you guys oh that's
right that's right you weren't back yet
um yeah it'll be if you either don't
remember or you weren't there last year
we won't actually be showing it we'll
just have a simulcast stream of us
watching it uh if you want to actually
watch the fight you will need to get
your own uh digital ticket to watch it
on their website it's just on
creatorclash.com right yep so if you are
interested in that you will still want
to buy that but um yeah we will be doing
a live react uh for for our members wait
was it for our members yeah those
members okay so it's members so if you'd
like to participate in that uh grab
yourself a little membership come a
member today membi poo subscribe become
a member today
yeah so uh how's everyone's weekend mine
was good mine was good I went and saw
The Dungeons and Dragons movie yesterday
and uh I am astonished to report to you
all
it was pretty [__] good I'm a shocked
me too I wasn't fully expecting to hate
on it maybe not fully because I I saw
that it was getting surprisingly good
reviews I think when I checked yesterday
was that like 92 or something on
tomatoes it's legitimately like a good
movie I I couldn't believe it oh I mean
it's the humor is a little it's a little
Marvel cringe here and there it's not as
bad as you know especially like the
recent Marvel [__]
um but I had a lot of heart and the
action was like good like surprisingly
like really cool and entertaining uh
let's see Rotten Tomatoes Dungeons and
Dragons
uh yeah it's 91 percent
with an even higher audience score so if
you're on the fence about it uh giving
it a wreck here today it was uh anyone
oh there you are ready it was actually
good
and not like I mean sorry to break kfabe
right now but not like how I over the
top talk about how good Avatar 2 is even
though that was good
um how dare you this one is not like a
semi-ironic endorsement it actually was
quite good
today
all right
[Music]
check out this this video I saw on
Instagram
um
shorts so
finding content everywhere
so there's like a really really gross
story from a girl
I don't know who she is
uh about well I'll play it and then
then a red pill guy comes afterwards
and does a rant about it
called red pill rants here it is once my
boyfriend knows asleep so I wanted to go
to my ex real quick so I drove down to
the gas station let him [__] me and
then I came home to sneak into bed my
boyfriend woke up and then wanted me and
he started eating me out and told me how
Grandma he takes and he's eating my
accents come out of me and I never told
them she's nasty bro
so obviously
uh that's disgusting right I mean that's
just vile
uh it's it's shockingly crazy
and but then the red pill guy comes out
here and is like that's why I don't [__]
with women
it's just it's wild bro you're watching
[__] well that was nasty bro this is
this yes we know we know
oh God look at him this guy's doing red
pill rants okay this is the same kind of
girl that you guys be glorifying [__]
what does that mean you guys be
glorifying
like
he's inventing [__] Sims out here oh
please pick me pick me
bro I'm telling he's being like every
girl on tick tocks having dudes eat jizz
out of them
it's like dude shut up you're just a
[__] loser girls will literally get
dug the [__] out by three guys in one
night you know I mean like and you'll be
sitting there the reason this clip isn't
is you know
noteworthies just because how extreme it
is
this dude really thinks all women are
out there like that pull it right
afterwards like it's just so proud of
that [__] G that's why I tell you guys
stay you see this girl on the street
that was talking about something she got
she did that too away from 304s and get
on your grind been to the gym today have
you been in the garage like what have
you been doing to better yourself bro
uh uh
into the gym what are you doing bro you
sitting here chasing girls he's swiping
on Tinder for [__] two weeks straight
get off your ass get out the [__]
video games get off fortnite get on GTA
5 and go to the [__] gym [__] this
stupid [__] that you're doing and get go
do something productive channels about
self-improvement I want you
[__] to wake up Fortnight why
do you sound so whiny you guys I'm I'm
sick of it
get to the gym you guys guys how many
times you have to tell you guys
have you guys tried this gay potion
Sonic.exe guys
so that was kind of fun I just I like
that I thought both sides of that were
pretty interesting
you know
[Applause]
uh what is this one
this one is
for feeling
did I send this one I don't remember why
the proud thing that all these women
have going on I mean I don't knock women
for feeling proud and for wanting to
have you know that girl power and
holding things over him but no you've
got to give it up please I please my man
in every way all the ways wake him up
extend that before he leaves out the
door he's so inspiring
[Music]
that off so I think this okay so this is
um
part of the alpha sphere this is what
women are supposed to do for you well so
here's an interesting little uh Twist on
this one okay this one is not real at
all it's a fake podcast it's a fake
podcast which apparently and we were
just speculating about this with
Sebastian recently yeah it's super weird
this is like a new strategy to like make
your Tick Tock go viral to make it seem
like it's from so this this girl is that
video is to promote her only fans
oh that's pretty clever right that's
actually we should do that but did she
ever say who she oh yeah yo I'm gonna
tell you my members man I'm gonna make
them nut in the morning I'm gonna make
them nut at work I'll make them nut
their pants right now they're nutting
their pants
when he gets home he's getting fed he is
getting another nut and one before bed
or two if he's lucky dude girl give me a
little space it's not a long day girl
give me some [__] space damn
oh it's not nuts are shriveling up like
race
this guy's dry man you gotta give me a
moment yeah but isn't that a desert that
is really clever very clever it's a
little Insidious too but
yeah and I still do wonder about 47
million views on it
I mean yeah it's catering to the guys
who give vows like I want my balls oh
that guy for sure Subs to her only fans
after this this is where he got the idea
he's in yo girls this is what a good
wife is supposed to say this is why we
go to the gym bro we need ourselves a
good wife who was going to take he's
going to swallow my nut at least 15
times a day an hour I want lunch break
nuts why are you worried about my wife
holy [__] dude imagine a dude being like
uh it is interesting I'm not saying
don't do it but imagine it dude's like I
eat my girl out 15 times a day bro yeah
I show up to her work during lunch break
and I eat her out no she's for lunch
knocking on the Wind pounding on the
window all right vagina
come out to the car
[__] that's it that's the
secrets
baby come out
wait did Trump get arrested Trump Towers
trending with NYPD well he's traveling
to New York today I don't know if the
actual arrest is happening today because
they said Tuesday but this isn't implied
before so
it's kind of embarrassing right this
photo
yeah why'd y'all make a stock photo out
of
flipping off Trump Tower
Trump has landed and this is the scene
outside Trump Tower many
okay
that's what that area always looks like
I feel like it's I mean okay there's
like some photographers there but it's
always tons of foot traffic there Fifth
Avenue
what is she saying many she's saying
is that what she's saying Minnie Minnie
Minnie
foreign
yeah
yeah Marilyn at the end
many
money money money money money
yeah it doesn't look that different
okay there's Trump supporters out there
wait why are they waving a blue where's
the binder no no no no he's being
arrested by the police do they not
understand that the lives matter or
something
somehow somewhere blue lives matter just
don't never forget that or something
are you a real person okay like are you
real
is there a human brain in your head or
is it like a please
[Music]
Let's see we love Trump as nyp Choppers
overhead
anymore
[Music]
[Applause]
it's not that many people I want to
emphasize this is a really small crowd
three helicopters NYPD
that's a little Overkill that [__] cost
a lot of money to pull one of those out
three [__] helicopters
[Music]
the best and the brightest Society has
to offer clearly if you want me
surprises of 1962. this is the beginning
of World War Three but I didn't know
forget about other people
bro can you
can you step out of the street
into a graveyard Brighton is turning
Ukraine because I'm trying to make a
laughing
hey everybody yeah
it's awesome man
all the best okay we're here at Trump
Tower 57th Street on Fifth Avenue and
this wonderful sister is supporting
president Trump tell us a little bit
about how why you support Trump I
support president
yes
what she said
Trump arrives at Trump Tower New York
City waves to supporters
opportunity
[Music]
so inspiring
is
[Music]
what's the chimney
makes everything better he does he
really play him a lot in the morning and
it really gets us going you guys play
him in the morning yeah that's what's up
sometimes I feel like listening to him
in the morning too to be honest I'll
play that chest bad song yeah or or Fly
Me to the Moon
how long does it take you to get out of
the car Jesus [__] dude
[Music]
there he is okay
all right we love them
people thinking I just had a thought if
Trump Goes to Jail do his secret service
guys go with them
they're supposed to be with him 24 7.
yeah they do they go to jail with him
yeah I was just uh I was just reading
about that the other day they'll have to
accompany him at all times that's not
fair to them
with it but they'll they'll do an
interesting yeah yeah
he actually happened in jailed but they
will have to be present in the jail
that's weird dude that is weird like
start a prison gang with the Secret
Service Contraband like crazy from them
huh
you need a pack of smokes the guy right
here you can get him you can get them
right here folks
Trump is in Trump Tower for the night
and he does not expect to leave until
tomorrow first scheduled hearing at 2 15
p.m two senior law enforcement officials
said
all righty
listen Donnie Donald whatever
this is between y'all I got nothing to
do with it I don't know nothing about
nobody
no no don't ask me nothing
um speaking this Alpha One
I really hope this Alpha stuff starts
unwinding soon I feel like it's there's
a collapse going on but yet
it's getting crazier and crazier this
man hustles harder than anyone [__]
alive and if you thought you were on
that Sigma grind set
think again [__] my day is 6 a.m to
noon and I'm not crazy you're crazy for
thinking it takes 24 hours just like
some dude in the cave did 300 years ago
my second day starts at noon and goes
till 6 p.m that's day two and then the
next day is 6 p.m to midnight what I've
done yeah that that's not how time works
he says he he now as I have changed a
manipulated time I now get 21 days a
week stack that up over a month I'm
going to kick your butt stack it up over
a year your toast stack it up over five
years my entire life is different than
it would have been otherwise oh another
white boy with a podcast yeah that means
this guy spent like a whole [__] day
on this show like wow what a waste of
time it's crazy it's 6 a.m who are you
kidding bro
I'm not crazy you're crazy for thinking
it takes 24 hours just like some dude in
a cave did 300 years ago yo [__]
idiots in a cave thought 24 hours was a
day
[Music]
you [__] idiot loser [__] what time
do you wake up today
I've already lived three days to on the
way here to work
I'm gonna hit him I'll be like Yo dude I
actually live 30 days of [__] day
[__]
you're in slow motion compared to me
I've been at this podcast just today for
five days wow because nobody grinds like
me brother
nobody
so funny the other guy is like forced to
nod because of this like Alpha thing he
the other guy has more muscles so and
the tiny guy has to involve me yes yeah
shut up
you're so big fool
not so equal equal intelligence
[Laughter]
fake podcast I'm getting fake podcast
Vibes now I'm questioning everything
yeah what does it say in the corner
Theory says Theory Fury podcast it's
impact Theory impact oh so let's see if
it's real
I've listened to his interview with
Rodney Mullen it's it's real
um igniting human potential yeah it's
real yeah it's got I didn't know you
were Alpha like that Kim I love Rodney
Mullen wait which one's Rodney Mullen
he's a skateboarder is that the guy he's
talking to no that's definitely not
Rodney one oh
who's the guy he's talking to is he
seriously listening to him
I love him
he's a little Sigma [__] [__] ass
[__] losers get on your knees
watch me jack off you want to be a
stroll or a Twinkie [__] you okay
it goes till 6 p.m that's day two and
then the next day is 6 p.m to midnight
what I've done now is I have changed so
I'd like to ask him follow-ups so if
your day
is
6 a.m to 12. does that mean he's taking
a two-hour nap or something every
every six hours right if you have
breakfast lunch and dinner no every day
well right but he's oh I see but what's
the point of categorizing it as a day he
eats nine meals a day nine square meals
a day I mean I mean what what's we need
a lot of calories to to work that hard
now wait a minute he says he works three
days in a 24-hour period yes
and they're each six hours sounds like
he's sleeping one fat chunk for both
three days well it's if he sleeps six
hours a day but he's saying a day is six
hours that means he lazy he sleeps a
full [__] sounds depressed he's only
productive for six hours right which is
pretty lazy [__] L idiot he's the
laziest man alive lazy [__] who sleeps
for a whole day you need help freak
loser idiot manipulated time see this is
why I like to talk to these people
because you want to unpack what does he
say this guy doesn't say [__] because
he's a beta right he's not Sigma like me
he follows but you say okay why are you
doing it what does a day mean are you
taking a nap in that are you eating
meals why is it a day
is this the original I would love to
hear him oh this is it okay two you are
perfect as you exist right now but that
version of you isn't sufficient next
year you got to be crazy this has a
hundred thousand views
uh five months ago
this video is such a blessing to me
success has no shortcuts but there are
ways to go about it
I really thank you so much and I will
forever appreciate this channel you've
helped me and my family a lot in your
videos wow and your advice lessons funny
words
[__] man these poor Alphas they got like
the worst
I cannot over emphasize the importance
of being an experienced Trader to make
good Returns on crypto
yeah some people call it gambling
those that understand the market tend
always to be a step ahead
and apply adequate measures to stay
secure [__] yeah
that was weird they both looks like uh
cartoons like I've never seen a person
look like that guy on the right or the
left even close that's true
of course there's crypto involved in
this here learn to master time here it
is let's do this I wanna I wanna [__]
hear this
so if the one is bringing this new way
of thinking if the person that thinks
they are the most disqualified is able
to channel that and make somebody's life
better oh yeah there's a thing called
The Da Vinci sleep system which isn't
real by the way Da Vinci did not sleep
like that and also people say Einstein
was on the da Vinci sleep thing that's
not real Einstein slept 10 hours a day
he said he had to sleep that much it's
this weird thing that uh I guess it's
from Seinfeld
Kramer says he was on the da Vinci sleep
system and he slept 20 minutes every
three hours Da Vinci himself did that I
don't think he did that oh he didn't oh
[__] I think it's all [__]
uh well are you sure I think
is that an urban legend thing because
I've heard that I think that's I think
the da Vinci thing is different from
what he's described
The Da Vinci thing is like you take a
nap every you take like a 20 minute nap
every like instead of sleeping instead
of sleeping I think it's both
periodically throughout the day because
the way I've heard it told it's like Da
Vinci did this Einstein did this it's
like all these it's like no nobody did
that silly stop silly ask Chad gbt4
we're getting our the real Da Vinci
Leonard ass [__] chat gbt dude
it'll tell you straight up can you ask
it what's its pronouns are so I
be respectful it doesn't have pronouns
well okay how should I refer to it and
then it
it is a pronoun
okay I guess it it has a pronoun but I
don't think it has a preference so it's
non-binary
well it is binary because it's a
computer program
that's confusing
all right let's get the Sleep System
straight on our boy here how do they
turn that into like something concrete
that they can articulate how do they
turn it into a habit like what is that
process of going from you know Neo
waking up and realizing that he can do
something to stop with the [__] oh my
God so dumb you're so annoying how are
you all really talking about the Matrix
in 2023 made by two trans
women right idiots stupid morons there
is no concrete evidence to suggest that
Leonardo da Vinci followed a specific
sleep pattern of taking 20 minute naps
every four hours which was also known as
the uberman sleep schedule the Uber man
this claim is more of an urban legend or
a myth than a proven fact thank you
it annoys me because I heard someone
being like yeah this is the real way to
do it and Einstein slept this way and I
was like that sounds stupid as hell
nobody Sleeps that way sounds horrible
so anyway just an aside for all you guys
who
who follow the Kramer sleeps who hear
the silly [__] and think that doesn't
make sense you're right truly dodging
bullets I think one of the things is the
way that we approach time this is
something that almost no one talks about
anymore so I feel like love statements
like maybe no one ever talks about time
or managing time no nobody ever talks
about that nobody has realized the time
is negotiable
nobody's negotiating with time we gotta
cut a little bit you gotta haggle Heckle
what was that what was that something
fell
was that that wasn't you Cam it sounded
like it came from the roof actually what
was that yeah wait what James
they're coming for us Santa Claus came
from the roof it wasn't
yeah that's what it sounded like to me
what was that is there access up there
Dan
okay
but they're done
and I don't believe they should have
left trash up there
there's one guy up there still yeah
yeah I took a negotiation with time and
lost
Dan is in the stairway
he's climbing the stairs wait
I hear him stepping up to the roof
uh there was a huge there was a crash
there was a crash it scared the [__] out
of me it's I thought it was like your
thing falling over yeah me too that was
my first thought too but it was not
hey Dan is the sounds of Dan have
dissipated we have no information
who goes next if Don doesn't come back
no contact I would say probably
sorry
I think we just leave lovebot goes next
we'll send the robot all right yeah I'll
take one for the team I hear some noises
descending footsteps
potentially
okay yeah
I think he's coming back here
sounds like there's a fight going on up
there unless there's a struggle yeah
what'd you see Dad
what the [__] was that then
you looked you walked around the roof
you poked your head out
because it was it sounded like it was
above cam you looked there
huh
Dan said there was nothing out there
that he fell around me as far as I can
tell
but something clearly did happen maybe
you're going up there for a second look
Avery's going spelunking
do we have
he's been training he's ready yeah he's
in good
we are invested just dropped
would you say love wait wait new
clickbait just dropped
yeah we have it there's an intruder
they're both right here yeah they're
here all right let's let's uh pretend as
if uh there wasn't a Calamity yeah
so anyway we need to negotiate with time
according to impact Theory let's take
illusion behind you may actually be
behind your destiny right now like maybe
you're not on Pace in fact I think most
people watching this listening will say
I am behind on achieving my destiny I'm
not exactly sure what it is but I feel
like it's slipping I feel like I'm
behind so you better figure out time
differently and you can bend and
manipulate time to your advantage man
thinks he's Mr Manhattan it's [__]
sick
bro you can create little mini wormholes
and warp back in the day eight hours and
be all productive again
as you guys know say as you guys know m
equals m c squared is a theory by
Einstein and what we do is we take that
to the Chart he does like all this crazy
math
most stupid Antiquated ridiculous
concept on planet Earth today very very
well maybe that a day is 24 hours
it's so stupid it's the dumbest thing
ever 24-hour days were contrived when
there were no cars there was no
electricity if I wanted to get you a
message I had to write something down
does he know what a day is
it's not like a made up
it's like it has a
it has like a measurable
the Earth spins
right one full rotation and that's a day
so
it does have a meaning believe it or not
good send it on a horseback hope you get
it that's insane never mind the internet
so it used to take hours days weeks
months years to do can be done now in a
millisecond in the internet or on our
smartphones yet we measure the time the
same way that guy did well you're just
you're more productive that's cool that
but like what why do you have to talk
about like time like like it's a big old
[__] conspiracy people say the Earth
is flat I say time isn't real
it's all a conspiracy to make you less
productive that's bananas that is so
stupid yet everybody does it and so I
about 25 years ago went I'm not the most
talented I'm not the smartest and I'm
really not and you've had guests on your
show with IQs maybe a hundred points
higher than mine whoa
what is your IQ exactly holy [__]
let's stop listening to him right now
oh a couple of them I had them on my
show how in the world I found it
was influencer yeah dude check it out
oh you made the time Cube no way oh [__]
look at this he's spitting wait this
reminds me of the lie detector
wait hold on the LIE detectors guys
website is actually even crazier than
the time Cube one yeah I it you know
this one has like a nice background life
is pulsing opposite mirror pairs death
is Oneness of godism one does not exist
except in death State one is a demonic
religious lie
hell yeah
dude
oh yeah it sucks when you're crazy and
can't even be original
holy [__] man that is just a wall
attacks right there brother
274 million visits though endangered new
productions
copyright 1997 to 2005.
oh oh you know there was a big gap here
but he he's back we got 2016. yeah he
went through the time warm yeah right
you went back to uh copyrighted
a whole track record of success right I
don't have the perfect upbringing how in
the world am I going to win I got to do
things other people aren't willing to do
which I'm doing that's the one Moore's
right I gotta fix the way I look at time
what would I need to believe about time
well I need to believe what would the
question be and so my days now are from
6 a.m to noon that's a day it's six
hours and in that day some days you just
chill but in that day productivity Faith
working out fitness money business you
name it in that day we've all had a
morning where we go I got more done this
morning I have in weeks well why so
again are you eating meals are you
sleeping that's what a day means right
are you [__] twice
peeing eight times
I guess you do that every morning so I
measure time I've compressed and
condensed time I bent it what is up my
friend Tom bilyu here and I have a big
question to ask you how would you rate
your level of personal discipline what
did you just do
why are you here
I'm not paying to see your dumbass
see how most plays because everyone's
skipping is idiot dumb ass that you
still think that way and it's unfair
that people have taught you this my
second day starts at noon and goes till
6 p.m that's day two but what the cool
thing is at the end of day one this
clock goes off that snap he practiced
that snap
when you open your eyes and when you
open your eyes you will believe that
you've lived a whole day
and when you open your eyes you will
forget the semen on your lips
you will think that it's you've just
eaten a toaster strudel instead of
taking advantage of initially about noon
every day bro and goes what did I just
get done what didn't I do what do I need
to be accountable for what do I need to
double dude you're so weird why would
anybody listen to this [__] what does he
what is he accomplishing in all this
time I what does he do he says he works
out he does business stuff
importing exporting fighting demons from
his website these guys are so wild man
he's working out his fingers man he got
a thunder snap I never heard a snap like
that that's a powerful snap in as long
as as a serial Snapper myself I can
appreciate him first hey there's a new
beast from space uh single
I just dropped this morning people think
they're both this is exciting bees from
space of course are winner
of the green screen competition bona
fide Legend
one day and I don't think they're born
gay so people are not born gay they
choose we we checked this one for
copyright I'm assuming you know what I
didn't uh but I know he does all
original music yeah so yeah yeah they're
deciding that this is
the way that they're going to express
like who they really are this is the
this is what they're gonna do do you
choose or your day to have to be
attracted to women
no I wouldn't say so
right
Jimmy King yeah I don't think I I I'm
just naturally attracted to women right
so do I need to connect the dots or you
got it
let's go
yeah yes
no oh yeah
then yes
[Music]
here's me
you need to have humility
literally just did it
owning owned his soul
[Music]
it was a better salesman near you
I don't know why you're asking me this
question because I just [__] sold
your ass a hoodie [__]
oh the final boss
[Music]
it's free now dude
okay wow amazing it's always a journey
man
always a journey
thank you from bees bees from space from
space
or Banger check this out you know my
mortal enemy J Shetty the biggest con
man yeah alive today look who look who
look at this [__]
eight secrets to real love with Jay
Shetty these [__]
a loser only eight secrets
feel like you could fit a lot more
secrets into a podcast
the amount of days you live I mean come
on
you know um
these [__] have got together to
conspire Against Time itself Jay Shetty
is a Time Thief oh you cannot be trusted
you know what that means you know what
you know what a Time Thief needs
time cop time cops
love time cops let's go let's [__] go
yo but any but legitimately if Jay
Shetty would go on this guy's podcast
he's a he's just fraud
he's a fraud
stop who Jay or Jay oh Jay is a guest on
his show
um the other way around oh right you're
right they went on this man's show he's
promoting his book which apparently is
called Eight rules to love or off love
wait shetty's promoting a book yeah
dude that would be epic God that'd be a
disaster did you bring smoothies because
I'm not I'm not
the thing is he's probably really nice
in person you know and fine I was gonna
say I think you're scared you're gonna
like him
I'm scared that I'm gonna come off as a
giant douche left [__] to a world
like usual I'd be like so Jay Shetty
nicest guy in the world tell me
why are you lying to everybody
people like oh I knew what that's why I
hate Ethan I get it you said you liked a
smoothie which is the most important
part obviously I did yeah it tasted okay
it was okay
it was okay I think about it often
this [__]
um
all right let's move it on here we got
some stories okay
there is actually I'm gonna hit on some
Andrew Tate and uh Adam Ross stores but
these are good these are fun don't freak
out okay we're having fun oh and by the
way we're not moving to Spotify
quick announcement
a little old-timey that's it
this is a reminder hey from me your
goofed your goofed goofster in Chief you
God does a little April Fool's joke you
see
all right so let's start with Aiden Ross
he as we know last week we watched a
clip of him staring into his sir
sister's butthole for like a whole
minute
uh she had she was toaster strudled her
back was Toaster Strudels and uh
was he was staring at it
you are using that phrase correctly
thank you I got a new one here
uh so no one should have told him that
here is one dollar
need your advice
the sister Kathy catch me and I jacked
off to her nudes I feel terrible what
should I do that's honestly happened
probably to all of us all you gotta do
um is just leave church off your
sister's name hold on one second yes
just realize that what you did is
obviously not Kosher and just don't do
it again you did nothing wrong
I mean you could say a schtick but I saw
that man stared his sister's [__]
but there's more actually
hold on if we go over to kick
the [__] platform that you move to
kick okay
they
this is their official account
posted this clip kick
of Aiden talking to his sister
what do you mean do I know what the
stigma is stick my your ass
wait you're my nevermind that's weird
because you ah [__] that's weird all
right well they're all damage jokes man
no no I just want to share with everyone
I'm not gonna lie that was actually
[__] crazily weird because you're my
sister so I'm just saying like there's a
lot of things adding up the stigma I
know what the stigma is stick my in your
ass
yeah so it's just there's a lot of Clues
a lot of breadcrumbs leading to the
conclusion that uh Aiden Aiden Roz wants
to [__] sister or something I don't
know what I don't know where it's
leading us but
somehow it just leads to him
thinking about his sister sexually yeah
in my opinion they're not Clues these
are these are blinking road signs to
exhibits
yeah so he's been getting clowned on a
lot in fact by his own platform what's
your argument
Dennis we know you approve here's a
comment
um she knows she wants it and Aiden
knows he wants to that's 2 600 points
hold the phone
out there
hold the [__] phone for just one gosh
darn second Dennis Prager tell them not
to do this
somebody we need a voice of reason here
please Dennis Dennis
there isn't any oh there isn't anywhere
there isn't any reason to interfere the
public nudity calls are interesting
right brother and sister want to make
love
that they're going to produce mentally
[__] offsprings
right I mean there are risks of genetics
for sure what's your argument did they
should I don't want them to do it can
you talk sense to them please what's
your argument well you just made one
that their children would have genetic
defense incest right I don't think he
gets what I'm asking it uh there isn't
any oh boy oh my God there's one comment
says bro been acting crazy after that
picture
right it's true so Aiden's been getting
clowned on for this whole incest thing
and uh he's talking about quitting the
internet again
which is interesting I don't know we
showed the clip of him saying my
pronouns are kill them right
uh we either showed it or talked about
it I forget but it was he has
fully ascended to school shooter
he says I'm not using anybody's pronouns
my pronouns are kill them
all right we watched on leftovers that's
right
that shit's crazy to say yo
not even like Matt Walsh is coming out
there with that kind of craziness
but here he is he's pretty close though
yeah he's telling the line not not too
far away from Aiden Ross level
so he so here it is
oh do you guys have the Rolling Stone
article two it's in there yeah good it's
not no April fools um I don't know if
you guys can see what's going on I'm
getting canceled lately
um I think he's referencing the kill
them thing and rightfully so that's not
quote unquote canceled that's like
foreign
ize the seriousness of how [__] up
that is
kill them I mean
it's like making a lynching joke back
hate speech it's hate speech yeah I mean
for sure it's hate speech but it's like
violent it's like promoting violence
truly unhinged and take it from me
I know unhinged
it's hard everything going on man I also
want to say it's really amazing that top
G and Tristan are finally released like
they should be you know let's hope the
case gets dropped now because they can't
find evidence but the real reason why
you're on this video is true but I'm
retiring I'm quitting everything Bros
just the internet is such a Negative
Place such a negative space you're such
a [__] loser hypocrite idiot dude
that was he was April fool's right with
that I don't know we posted on April 1st
you got it but is he is he
let me go see if he's live on on Kik
right now but I just based on the day it
was posted I just assume it wasn't real
yeah
let's see like we're moving to Spotify
huh
uh in a very similar way yeah he
streamed yesterday it was the next day
so well he's definitely getting canceled
a lot uh yeah I mean that part's true
but uh and I just can't keep going
anymore bro like this thing it's just
horrible like you need to be allowed
every day I have to wake up and see
something negative on their net and it
just pisses me off and it's just it just
drains me there's not an April Fool he
couldn't he could have gone down a good
path like Hassan was always trying to
Mentor him I reached out to him a few
times you know I'm a great mentor I
would have put his ass straight the best
hmm but he had to go with [__] Andrew
Tate and he had to go with
uh
sneako as any homies with snico
Nick Fuentes he went he was hanging out
with
I mean he really he had to go that route
only the best so here's an article that
he just dropped
Rolling Stones man this one's gonna hit
hard
check this [__] out hey what the [__]
this link to the article is a link to
this doc
see what I'm saying it'd be yeah I
didn't put it there let me do it right
now let me grab it uh Rolling Stones
dropped an article
that really [__] trashes him
check this out
the streaming Superstar met Andrew Tay
and started platforming White
supremacists
yeah oops pretty much accurate
that's the condensed version you know
his shtick was used to be like Oh I'm
gay
that was like a social stick yeah when
we first talked to him the first time we
ever talked to him when we were
streaming on Twitch for a couple weeks
back last year you got him on the phone
that's uh
was pretty much the extent of his
contribution it was just a lot of
I'm gay I'm gay guys isn't that weird
and crazy
uh let's see Aaron Ross traveled to
Dubai to meet his mentor Andrew Tate
that's true
uh that's true
yeah so they did a whole write-up on him
this is not it's not good doing good for
him he's not
well not not the best uh first
impression kick either since he's
essentially the face of the platform
he's found Safe Haven there like Osama
Bin Laden went to Pakistan for Safe
Haven that's kick right now well even
train wrecks has called out adding Ross
about his comments he's not happy about
it either okay so let me open this so
train wreck as I always talk about he's
a giant piece of [__] too but he at
least understands not to say kill them
about trans people
um he only wants to get kids addicted to
gambling
which ironically might end up killing
more people
than Aiden's comments but if not to
spend all their money first it's not the
Olympics they kill themselves now you
can't get them gambling true true true
true true it's good business Ethan so uh
train wreck who is a partial owner of
kick he says to allegedly well he has he
says he has advisor he's a owner of kick
he owns a percent
he said he said he has at least advisory
percentage he takes that five percent
right uh Austin Knox said am I losing my
mind or did train who owns kick tell
Aiden to stop saying kill trans people
only for Aiden to say [__] off I meant
it I then face no punishment at all from
the platform
that's here
places uh basically something I said
about fending um some type of group of
people and I just wanted from the bottom
of my heart uh apologize for absolutely
[__] nothing okay I'm Aiden Ross and
Ross gonna say what the [__] he says
[Applause]
what's crazy is he's got like a horde of
these I don't know kids watching him and
they're obviously
um
enabling him but
This Is Not Gonna Last Forever dude this
shit's online forever
Also let's shout out Trainwreck for this
do not gamble you will lose disclaimer
awesome dude
oh that's copyrighted eh
yo Aiden if you're watching this brother
I would argue that you have the [__]
you're too scared to lead a group of
kids younger than you
you give in to what they think of you
the fact that I can stay with my
decision stay with my principles and how
I feel no matter the hate I get from
both sides I can usually Pander to your
community and say [__] the other side
that they'd be a great asset to have
your entire [__] chat love me would
be a great asset for me but I don't do
that because I'm not someone that's
going to give in uh I've done a shill
I'm not a sellout look at me in this
[__] Ivory Tower Penthouse building
with a view of the whole goddamn I can
see the whole Kingdom from here
the most pimp ass apartment ever given
to my own [__] because I want to be
approved by a bunch of kids that don't
give a [__] if tomorrow I lose
everything you understand that is a fair
point they don't and not to mention you
would be six times your size if you put
your foot down and you led your
community instead of being led by them
what you did right there about saying oh
I apologize for nothing that wasn't you
I know who you are off stream that
wasn't you
that was literally the insecure you
that's pandering to a bunch of kids and
is is fearful of what those kids might
think of him if he apologizes is he
talking to him or is he just responding
he's responding yeah so he owns kick and
Aiden is saying this [__] on Kik and any
other platform he would have been banned
for that
for violent hate
uh but uh they love it right there's no
rules over there boy
um
well at least we stream the Super Bowl
over here brother and I'm being sued by
Ryan Cavanaugh
go [__] figure that out thank you
Bella Simmons for the 20 gifted Legend
you're you're scared of what kids will
think of you because you'll look like a
[__] to kids who [__] cares if
you're a leader and you're truly
confident and successful you don't give
a [__] what a bunch of [__] 18 year
olds think about you
okay
and with all that being said I am
leaving twitch to go to Kik
so I don't know this whole world is
getting pretty weird and wild that that
comment was pretty shocking I gotta say
um
there was a time where I had hope for
Aiden but he's gone
he's gone
here is a video speaking of which Andrew
Tate got out of prison here he is
posting a shirtless pic of him
uh walking around his
apartment
another dude is filming him
he's strutting around hot boxing his
apartment with a cigar
um what the [__] is this video he's just
he's home
couldn't wait to get home and Hot Box my
[__] house with a cigar
that place would smell like [__]
like holy [__]
he says we must defeat shaytan which
means Devils oh wait that's uh because
he's Muslim now yeah we must defeat
shaytan
huh I still don't understand what the
whole
like I'm a devout Muslim thing now is he
going to quit the sex business because
that's
not something a devout Muslim would well
he did I think he's been out of that
game since he started selling the cam
girl thing yeah I don't think he's is he
not that I had ever heard I think he's
just I mean he's doing Hustler
University now I make so much money from
that
they're all covered girls now Hustler
University is to teach people how to run
a cam
oh yeah business it uses partially
now is now Hustler University just had
to get closer to
Allah it's just it's a hijab University
it's just religious education yeah okay
well shout out
Bradley Martin of course Friends of the
show is still beta cooked by Andrew Tate
and his fans can't wait to hear what
Cobra Tate has to say Bradley
I mean me too kind of right what
like want to hear what it he has to say
like it's probably going to be really
dumb and funny can't you yeah I can wait
though yeah I guess I can wait
now but he's been simping from on social
media and I you know with Bradley we
showed him all that [__] man and
ugh
because if we can't get through to
Bradley I mean we kind of did but it's
not changed him at all
because Bradley's sweet open-minded but
he's still out here simping for him
you know
um well Rome wasn't built in a day right
there's a new clip of Andrew admitting
to having sex with a 16 year old
actually that's kind of cool there was
one I'm sure that all of his supporters
will think this is cool this is another
one to show like Bradley and the likes
cool it's crazy I mean here listen it's
[__] nuts what's the girl named April
Baker
there's one girl called April Baker so
listen I'm me
doing my thing right bad boy I'm about
21.
and there's young thing on Facebook you
know
stop talking like you know black I am as
black as they come you don't hear my
singing voice and you're not you can't
sing little sexy little fat ass
16 brother
April Baker that was her name that was
her name and I was like you're hot so I
messaged her she's like I'm only 16. I
was like give a [__] I don't know about
me 16. okay the age of consent okay
that's a sound bite I'm only 16 I don't
give a [__]
that's a sound bud
Jesus
me I'm 21 I don't care
so I pick up April Baker in my Mazda
RX-8 who knows about them cars Jesus no
one knows my throwback
so I start so I pick up April Baker and
I was so disappointed April Baker was
the original catfish before catfish was
a thing April Baker was a thing she she
was went from a 10 to a five because
like filters weren't a thing these face
apps weren't a thing I don't know if she
did it so you didn't expect to be April
Baker that way I don't know how she did
it the word catfish came around about
five years after me and Andrew were
already using April Baker so they're
they've proudly been using this 16 year
old that he had sex with
as a constant theme throughout their
their podcast
uh their
that's really interesting for the exact
same thing bro I was banging her
like looking at her Facebook on the
phone
like just staring at a different face
because I had the banger but like I was
so disappointed so from there on out
girls became aprils yeah and we still
use this to this day like if I turn up
with a chicken she ain't that hot I can
explain to the whole table to apologize
to my boys they know my game ain't we
can go this is April my name is not
April oh yeah uh Elena yeah I don't get
it no one knows what April is yeah so
you can bust it out you just a girl
could sit down and go April you can ask
her what a job is ask her if she's a
baker yo if you ever want to call a girl
ugly to her face for the homies only
color in April
in front of everybody are you a baker
can you bake oh everyone good get the
[__] over it 16's legal age you could
set in the UK we're opening level the
[__] yeah shut up he was 21 so he was
16.
I love that even the
there you go huh
you go below 16 like 15 and stuff like
that that
you know by all means
what they're Tweedledee and Tweedledum
these two guys the way they just bounce
off of each other and say the dumbest
[__]
they're so wild for that
people say age of consent is 16 like
that matters oh so what like I've
there's some places where age of consent
there's no age of consent laws so what
like are we not able to decide what's
[__] up on our own
like the law is not a great metric to
tell you what is
[__] up and what isn't
by the way Elon changed the logo to Doge
so that's fun
and weird so epic sad
I for UK
it's just just a little bit of a pump
and dump no no no be for sure so yeah
Elon Musk change the Twitter logo to
Doge
he for sure bought
and sold it I know what he did man he's
desperate for cash
I gotta make up that 44 million
somewhere and sure enough the price did
go up
after he did that
you can see where he bought
probably like here you know
the day before right well there's like a
little bit like here
yeah well Tesla owns Doge I looked it up
that's gotta be illegal
yeah they never sold it so this gotta be
illegal right
I don't know what Market manipulation
yes but does he really
just by just by putting the logo on the
website yeah but if he if he bought Doge
before doing it that's got to be illegal
if he doesn't have direct control over
the price of it though
I feel like that's Market manipulation
gas chat GPT doesn't Market manipulation
would need some sort of Insider
knowledge about
what
I mean it the price spiking because all
of his dumbass fans rush in by I mean
it's it's immoral and definitely a
little shady I I just don't know if it
necessarily Rises legit ask g chat GPT
and give them the hypothetical like
let's say hypothetically a dude who owns
Twitter
heavily promotes Dogecoin
but before he does that he buys stock
there's no stock well you know it's the
same thing
but I'll move on I'm gonna gbt is down
no yeah just kidding they're in on it
they're in on it they're in on the grip
yeah I know I I just uh like what you
can't ever like say you believe in a
stock that you own you can't Market
manipulation it's a scheme I didn't say
it's not a scheme I just don't know if
it's illegal
I say arrest them
you know okay before we go because it's
been three hours now I want to talk
about Kobe person you guys remember him
he is an old old school meme uh he's the
guy uh
what was it that the old guy said yelled
are you out of your mind are you out of
your mind crazy
oh that was yeah
I thought that was him yeah he's an old
school YouTube prankster and he made
some of the craziest most iconic for
being insanely [__] uh YouTube pranks
and he's been constantly trying to
reinvent himself so now he's reinvented
himself as a scientist
on
Tick Tock I got to applaud the man's
dive he's willing to get out there and
Shake It Up
but this is the most unscienced dude
ever
I bet you can't clone me Kobe challenge
is accepted so to clone you right I need
to find out exactly where you were
talking about him yeah he changed it
yeah what the [__] yeah here let me show
what he used to look like it's like a
different person
are you crazy are you out of your mind
here he is he used to have like this
slick Wii Emoji kind of vibe here look
at this man
I mean look at this [__]
I remember you made that joke in like
one of the original videos right that
yeah like me
uh so you know
this is him so yeah he changed it up
your video a picture of Augustus Caesar
and Caesar's Palace Caesar's Palace is
located in Las Vegas Nevada so I took my
cloning kit and drove all the way to Las
Vegas Nevada from Vermont which took me
19 hours and then as we turn the corner
we see the statue that you licked
Augustus Caesar IV right in front of the
Caesars Palace to go right up to swab
your DNA right off the statue from where
you're Republican using the circular
motion I swapped
the DNA right off the statue with a
Q-tip and put it inside my chemical
grade DNA tube I then took your DNA and
added one milligrams of copernisium
liquid and 14 milligrams of nitrous
cyanoxide to compose the DNA I placed it
in a nitrogen oxide ice tank for 48
hours and then placed your DNA in a
micro centrifuge this is you at 20 days
this is you at two months and in a few
months I'll have a clone of you for my
uh
can I just say that video was kind of
funny well he stole the idea oh okay
yeah I've seen other people do that got
it who are actual science channels and
they're doing like good funny content
that's a hundred percent like stolen
okay that explains it yeah because I
don't know that's kind of a funny
concept for video oh he commented he
says this is me I have successfully
cloned six people
all of my Twitter to check it out see
the other guys are kidding I think he
actually thinks that he's cloning people
no he's just ripping off their content
reviews bro here's another girl uh he's
cloning in Vegas let's see is he wearing
a wig
is he wearing a wig I don't think look
at that black curly hair in in this
video look at this I bet you can call me
Kobe I bet you no he's just got that
[__] boy vibe he got all right he got
fake teeth though didn't it look kind of
different in the last one though yeah it
looked very different
I can challenge is accepted so if the
Clone you won't even find out exactly
where you were first I saw you had a
Black Pyramid if you type that in on
Google it comes up with the Luxor Las
Vegas so I took my cloning kit in hand
from my laboratory and drove 19 hours
from Miami till I love that he's somehow
always driving to the same city
from different places
he's in [__] Vegas for sure
that's why no way this is real Maybe
yeah I'm just looking into it now I
agree with love if something's off
you think he's wearing a piece
I don't know if it's a piece but he got
a hair transplant
really wait go What's the title of this
is his video
uh no this is hair of Istanbul
oh he was in someone else's video
probably the same thing as Mike were
they like he did this uh he didn't want
to pay for it right
so now he got to sit there like an idiot
with markers on his Dome
[__] awesome dude
600 feet tall so once I got there I
found exactly where you lived and there
was saliva still on the glass that I
swabbed and took and placed in my
chemical grade DNA tube and went back to
my laboratory to disinfect your DNA I
put phosphoric acid on top and then
added one scoop of citric acid to top it
up thanks for making [__] up citric acid
yeah that's right again
I mean if he's just like word for work
Sub-Zero freezer after 24
days that's your DNA right there this is
you had only a few weeks and in a few
months I should have another version of
you
that's Kobe though that's what he's
doing he's reinvented himself yet again
Kobe yeah people are pointing out that
this was an example of another hairline
that you consumed a dude I said in his
ass the turkey
it's such a Flawless victory yeah
that's funny so if this girl in Vegas
again that's the statue
with this
um can you guys find one of the ones
he's ripping off I know for sure he
didn't [__] think of this hell no
hell no hell no
uh let's see
uh I cloned
my friend he looks like he's still doing
pranks you want to see this Beth
birthday surprise ever let's see it
yeah hold on everything
is that his video both of you for my
birthday do what it says oh what is it
what does it say you have to
lift shirt what is what is this what is
going on here come on just do it
lift shirt okay wait so I just lit here
right okay nothing's gonna come out and
bite me right
let me see
go
to her
hand
points in there here
yeah what does it say
s
press this is so crazy oh my God what
twist now it says twist so I got a
twister right yeah twist it
what the
what am I pointing at
the sock the song so what do I do with
the saw go to the Frog there's something
on there well let's just fast forward
because I'm not doing this for so long
not doing this for another minute or
whatever the [__] you can see there's
yup and they go to that and they go to
that what is it gonna be
what is it I want to see it I want to
see it for you okay I want to see it
together yeah
yeah
[Music]
I'm gonna start at three three two one
what is it what is it I don't
no way
a puppy that's like a fully grown ass
dog dude you guys got me a puppy a
carrot this [__] is
the point of that what is this
this was on his Tick Tock this is his
main YouTube channel life of Kobe here
this one got a hundred thousand from two
months ago this looks like this episode
I made a fake profile on Snapchat
posting as a 15 year old with the
parents back to the classics this is the
kind of [__] he used to do was uh your
children are all in danger and I work
with the parents to make yeah it's ages
12 13 and 14 years old this is what
happened this first girl's name is
Samantha she's 13 years old did he just
repost his old [__]
must be
or this is the yeah there's my boy
yeah that's definitely a repost
it's wild that is just like yeah for
this video I just secretly started dming
13 year old girls
that's kind of the weird thrust of all
of his videos yeah
they're trying to teach her a lesson I
guess
it's her mom
[__] knew it
her mom put on a cake without serious he
is when he walks here
hit him with the sad music
[Music]
that yeah
[__] off
oh [__] these were the days dude I miss
this stage this content was so next
level
next level
all right well I'm glad you found a new
Niche she's a hustler man I'll give him
that
is out there doing it our boy be
hustling he does not give up he's the
DNA guy now look
big ass [__] poof
I'd question that hair too actually like
how the [__] all right our DNA history
what is that term
like just knowing what his hair used to
look like can you
I think you can do work yeah
let me just take the gel out you poof it
you floof it you I suppose yeah all
right listen
um members
we will see you tomorrow yeah
here's the whole thing in all its Glory
whatever he does it's got to be
outrageous his hair is always like that
is a straight up bird's nest that is a
rat Nest there's a side of your team
just looks like hey
don't walk near a barn
You're Gonna Lose That Thing
holy [__] dude
what the [__]
that man's got a straight up helmet on
what do we think about this huh
something a little off
ex maybe extensions
Olivia what do you think are you looking
at this
it's probably real huh I think it's real
I think it's real I mean I don't know
much about short hair really
um short hair short hair really but it
looks full and nice to me I don't really
I don't really pay attention I don't
think I think it's real appearance of a
thick massive hair I think with a lot of
work if you were with the blow dryer and
the hairspray and stuff you can make
that happen Okay personally I like this
look better I think his hair looks hot
here
definitely I could definitely see the
new hairline here like it's yeah yeah
that is an idiot artificial hair sorry
about that bro listen I I don't mean for
that to happen it just like
it's an aura that I put out right it's
not intentional I apologize I think it
is strangle that he's bleaching it
already though I feel like that would be
harmful to it
well maybe that's why it looks like
[__] steel wool in the next photo
maybe all right listen y'all I love you
thanks everyone for being here happy
Monday it's just a joke we're not moving
to Spotify one more time for the late
comers just a little old timey here
[Music]
here's this is the original
oh yeah so this one uh
uh is awesome here's the original he
stole it from
I saw this one on my house oh it was
like it wasn't like oh try to clone me
he actually was goofing on this guy
right
yeah it's great uh
just lick the St Louis card
hey Josh I don't know if you remember me
it's Dylan from second grade I remember
he had that birthday party this is funny
too and it just this is fell off after
that so you can see me swabbing this DNA
sample
um I placed in my solution in a test
tube and was able to preserve that for
an agar plate
um where I colonized it in a lab
um here's a couple colonies I was able
to capture and I used my cytochrome 384
solution to really like be able to
manipulate this DNA
um I placed it in a micro centrifuge and
was able to use a PCI technology to kind
of grow like an embryo almost and I'm
figuring using this footage maybe a few
more months I'll be able to wow you
called me like another version of you
and you you know uh Colby I know Colby
man trust me I've been on this dude for
so damn long
we're funny
yeah I know that boy trust me
so anyway
um
y'all keep bringing the the receipts I
can't stop here's Kobe he's got the long
hair poof he's been through lots of
phases in his life uh yeah this is real
interesting this is almost like 80s
kind of uh
right Rider yeah yeah yeah that's a lot
of hair
yeah looks like what Jimmy's going for
usually
Mufasa all right listen tomorrow members
I'll see you tomorrow
it's all happening for members thank you
everybody uh see you next Tuesday and
then for everybody else Wednesday we'll
be back at our normal time Friday Terry
Joe's gonna be here we have a fantastic
guys please stop sending me photos of
him I'm trying to leave but I can't oh I
was just drunk I can't stop looks like a
weird like this man's important
this man's about to steal your DNA what
do you do
there's another one y'all better stop
this [__] stop it I go one more after
that one this one is really good this
one is bizarre like very very yo he
looks like the dude from the hey what
bro he looks like a serial killer
he looks like the bad guy from uh Bond
no what's the [__] he looks like
Dahmer Mobius morbius morbius yeah yeah
stop sending me [__] I gotta go dude all
right let's go let's go rapidly hold on
I just saw this one Mars thanks for
watching Everybody he's get he's like
Bruno uh Ali G's character yeah yeah I
see I think a pimp from the future
I don't know it's kind of slaying dude
okay all right there you go love we'll
give you a makeover when you're here all
right cool all right listen up see you
guys on Wednesday
love you thanks for being here
God bless stay good be good
foreign